to hello
something just hit me there
I had a couple bites of barbecue
Lays
sweet honey barbecue lays to hit me off
start my day right good Smoky flavor
good Smoky flavors but it hit me right
here
welcome everybody
dude dh3 podcast it's Monday
March 27th it's sunny it's beautiful
outside
it's finally
getting a little bit nicer around here
and uh well I'm very happy to be here so
thank you everyone for being here how
are you guys how's everyone's weekend
everybody feeling good
all right good baby okay okay okay
specifically how are you feeling you're
feeling strong you're feeling powerful
yeah I'm excited a few weeks left you
feeling you're getting your cardio up
where it needs to be yep inshallah
inshallah I feel so powerful and then
you get you get a Ramadan exemption
right because of your training yeah
that's pretty dope do you need to apply
for that or something I don't think it's
legit but I'm just I'm just doing wait
seriously you don't get an exemption I
mean depends on who you ask no I mean as
long as you make it up I think it's okay
but some people will say it's not well
if you didn't it would be really [__]
your training up wouldn't it yeah but
like in Dearborn my hometown like people
will like be fasting during two days of
football and stuff so
in my opinion God is going to want you
to win that fight thank you I agree I'm
not familiar too much with the with the
you know the profit your profits uh old
brand
um
but I have a feeling he's gonna want you
to win that one I agree yeah thank you
and mine too Moses Allah
they've all come together Jesus Christ
himself they're all huddled up and
they're holding hands and they're
jumping going baby
thank you that's an image that I think
will help get me through
yeah if somebody could just draw that to
help
everybody's coming together I'm feeling
good though man I can't wait to watch
you beat dad's ass
yeah it should be fun
you feeling like you're gonna win what
your confidence levels
see I I'm feeling good I'm not the type
of person though to just say oh I'm
gonna win no matter what uh but they
teach you in boxing that you're supposed
to have that mentality which I don't
really have because I just feel like
it's kind of embarrassing if you lose
then but I'm feeling good so well
compared to last time when you fought
hondar how confident are you feel like
this time versus last time oh a lot a
lot more confident definitely big time
last time I didn't know what the hell's
gonna get to I was terrified so
wow this is exciting
it's all happening
cool yeah so um obviously you guys seen
the title there's a huge announcement
coming
[Music]
I am
excited to share this with you
I'm nervous to share this with you
you know I don't know how to really even
say it
um but I'm just gonna come out and say
it
because it is such a huge announcement
I'll do half now and half at the end of
the show how's that
so the first part of this announcement
that I think is very important is that I
have become I have your host Ethan Klein
they keep going keeping contact
your host of the H3 podcast me Ethan
Clyde have accepted nay
I have
taken back
conquered back the title
of true alpha dog
[Applause]
I am infiltrating the alphas at every
single possible level
is that Tick Tock no it's me oh that's
amazing version of the alpha Zone dude
that's [__] epic you made this yeah
let's go dude these guys don't make
their own Alpha remixes
I am coming and I'm bringing the war to
them
no longer
will they get the
Frank what did they call it the alpha uh
genre
bronc
what's that what is that
you think you're Funk I'm funk
I'm the funk King
and that's it
look at this
love we've been juicing the ever living
God out of this kid this child Sebastian
yes dude thanks for the dub idiot
and by the way I'll also say that we're
having our best month on the podcast in
years and I'll tell you guys I'm not too
proud to share this with you guys this
month we're at minus 3 800 Subs
which means we've only lost 4 000 Subs
this month which is let's be honest
we're coming up let's go we're slowing
we're on that Ethan incline oh Ethan
incline that's what the [__] is up New
Era Ethan incline that's right the
button era baby and I'll tell you what
else is inclining the slope on my
treadmill
it's not even a joke that's just facts
thank you
I've been live streaming on Tick Tock as
I do the treadmill for an hour bringing
the heat to the alphas there and you
know I go through the chat and I let
people into the call
to see it I want to say who real Alphas
talk to me
you know for the amount of [__] that
people talk about me on tick tock where
are they
they literally run and hide when I give
them the opportunity to say that [__] to
my face because they're betas
so this is it check out this clip we
just posted uh three hours ago right
love this one's doing really well I mean
it's already gone
it's doing so good Jesus half a million
so I think this one's on the way
potentially to um
to Alpha Tick Tock here it is are you
still on antidepressants yes I am so
you're currently I thought no why are
you taking it because um bro are you
dumb like I mean you are he goes I never
even addressed this point it was like
he goes are you on antidepressants yes
are you depressed no he's like then why
are you on them idiot dumb
I go that's like being like are you
hungry
do you eat food yes are you hungry no
then why are you eating food dummy
shut up Sebastian really that dumb
yeah I was depressed I was having a hard
time a few years ago people that are
feeling depressed oh this is copyrighted
you think
I think so yeah
Zach
[Music]
I guess
I guess it's quiet so it might actually
be masked
laughs
it's not I guess this really doesn't hit
as hard does it
it's kind of hard don't really hit that
hard I guess
but it is going popping off
mm-hmm
that's it
here I am from live yesterday if you
guys want to know what that's like
we gained like 40 000 followers this
week by the way that's it that's it
watch out Sebastian I love house first
of all
it is it is humorous and it's goofy that
I'm bragging about only losing 4 000
Subs but
it is actually an improvement and I do
think it's funny that Sebastian's like
dude your Channel's dying
while simultaneously giving us the
biggest boost in Subs we've seen so
thank you Sebastian I just want to be
left alone I know I know if this is your
first time tuning in today we're happy
to have you please hit that subscribe
button so we can be in the positives
let's go green for Sebastian let's
dedicate it to our boy hit that
subscribe button folks thank you Cameron
yeah here let's see what this is like I
don't even know what clip this is it was
a lot for a minute
oh yeah I was trying to do
you meant what was the name of that band
that they used to be on treadmills and
okay go I was trying to do the okay go
thing
where I let the tremo pull me back but I
kept getting really scared that I was
gonna fall off
let's go I guess we have it muted
because I have the music blasting in the
room here let me hear it for a sec I I'm
curious how loud it was
come on
let's get that funk music going yeah I
am funk I am the Funk Master
[Applause]
it's good stuff guys it's all happening
that's not the only massive change
there's a huge announcement coming at
the end
[Music]
you see how I hit that okay go
impressive right scared though
you get scared it starts to drift too
far then I run
I I couldn't even tell if they knew
that's what I was doing
yeah
exciting stuff
thank you thank you thank you
so
I wonder who else we could invite on you
know to keep it going
I could message Aiden
when he's done watching porn of his
sister maybe he'll come call into the
show
let me think about it hold on
Aiden I love all the comments about
Sebastian saying rumor has it he's still
thinking today
yeah Aiden Ross actually
who is uh of course an alpha this kid
again Kevin Ethan and Kevin my hairline
might be receding now but the beef
continues well if you keep this [__] up
you're gonna have any hair left on your
head better chill Kevin
you don't want this beef
Dan is he came here with a flat of hair
I've been battling Ethan for years look
at me
right
this is pretty funny to be honest Aiden
Ross uh I guess
his sister doesn't only fans is that
right correct
which is actually the irony of that is
quite exceptional seeing as
he is
turned like such a red pill that I'm
assuming he probably just looks down and
hates
sex workers now it's just a fact only
fans girls you know
and so people have turned it into a
sport of tricking Aiden into looking at
nude pictures of his sister
is that [__] up or is it funny I think
it's funny considering it's Aiden what
are your thoughts on that
definitely ironic definitely ironic
right I mean you can't see it's not
but it's the internet what do you expect
man but it is his reaction's funny this
man just stares into his sister's
[__] for like 30 seconds like
straight up like she's on her all fours
yeah her butthole is like out
and somebody just
I guess uh
just to say it's finished on her
I mean
not to be crude but that's what it is
and watch his ex Russia's reaction is
quite interesting here
[Music]
wait why is it so low quality what the
[__]
it's okay he someone sent him a video at
it
the cuts to
his sister
you know on all fours and the whole chat
can see it he's on Kick so
this man is staring into his sister's
[__]
I mean that he's just staring at that
man
I might have been joking bro that [__]
is just too far bro
all [__] aside that [__] is way too
[__] far bro
y'all literally just went too [__]
far with that without him bro
that's not even funny bro y'all just
literally show me my naked sister
was not on her back bro that [__] is too
far it's just
wait I want to hear that again with the
music Zach hold on right right is it
right as it kicks in hit me with that
am I even joking bro that [__] is just
too far bro
all [__] is way too [__] far bro any
what would they do take [__] fall
right there with that one bro
that's not even funny bro y'all just
literally show me my naked sister
with nut on her back bro that [__] is
too far it's just
oh man
well you know now this is going to be
the new meta on his stream right is to
try to get him to look at pictures of
his sister naked now I don't know the
lore of all this stuff but I remember
when she started doing all fans he was
really upset right he did he hated it he
didn't want her to do it is that right
does anyone have that lore maybe you
love
no actually I didn't know he thought his
sister even
yeah I mean it is it's horrible right
but at the same time it is Aiden Ross so
brother and sister Wanna Make It money
okay Gregor that's Dennis
Dennis my argument is that it's gross
Dennis we get it
thank you Dennis it there isn't any
there is it's gross dude is that not
enough the public nudity calls are
interesting this man is [__] sick in
the head Dennis Gregor it's your
argument
yeah I don't know is it [__] up or is
it funny should people keep doing it or
should they stop they're gonna be both
right no I mean
it can be both a lot of times because
it's [__] up it's funny because it's
[__] I imagine it's 50 50. I imagine
it's uh
imagine his sister probably isn't
thrilled about it either and it is her
she's her bunghole okay uh being used
for the for the prank so from a business
perspective that's probably really good
marketing for her he just pulled up on
that some of her content stared at it
straight and his little the little uh
pre-teen boys there are gonna flock
and apparently she's doing like hardcore
stuff too which is interesting well
um let's do a poll let's say is it funny
is it gross or is it both I see lots of
reactions or both yeah is it it's funny
it's not gross there's companions all
over the place actually it's funny
and it's not funny all right throwing it
up okay this this
comment predicted it what what where was
this from uh he has a highlight on his
official YouTube channel called uh Aiden
reacts to his sister making an only fans
okay so what the [__] do you want he's
in the content yeah well all right it
looks like the both is the clear winner
here yeah
yeah and I feel the same way it's a
little funny it's a little gross and
it's it's a lot of both stop laughing
it's not funny so I'll be proudly
viewing any more such instances if if
y'all keep getting him I will be here
watching and just saying that was
horrible all these bad pole people
come on
it's a it's this is that Revenge okay
someone asked is that revenge porn I
don't want to get angry or this early in
the morning please
she's selling it you dummy how can it's
not revenge porn She's literally selling
it on only fans bro stop it
she's gonna give me heart palpitations
at [__]
middle of the afternoon man with those
kind of comments
I'm wrapping up this pole the both is
the clear winner here
52 a true Alpha stairs for 30 seconds to
his sister's naked body with not all
over her back
a real Alpha stares into the abyss
deeply into his sister's [__] and is
able to diagnose hemorrhoids
right that's a feminist Aristotle quote
actually it is a shame for a brother not
to stare into his sister's [__]
that was he was kind enough to let chat
right he gave him enough time to finish
themselves that was thoughtful he cares
yeah
yeah it is a shame for a man to grow old
without seeing the beauty and strength
of which his body is capable and also
his sister's [__] let me finish let
me finish Bobby John just 10 seconds
longer
dude I am the new Alpha y'all that music
gets me hyped up Zack ah good I'm glad
I'm the Funk Master
[Music]
we're coming for you guys I'm telling
you your the time is over Alpha time is
over we killed it last week with
Sebastian
do you think it's a good idea or a bad
idea to invite Aiden Ross on the show
I feel like it's
I mean it'd probably be good content I
guess but that's it that's where the
conversation ends no I don't I don't
think he would take it seriously that's
the thing it won't it won't be anything
comparable no Nexium or or the whatever
who other [__] that guy was last week I
already forgot his name what is his name
oh Sebastian right of course Sebastian
and his partner Sebastian right the two
sea basses little Sebastian
maybe his partner's short pathetic loser
Sebastian wolf Sebastian yeah I think
Sebastian and Will Smith
all right Aiden come on let's provide
any evidence as to into sex trafficking
he was just talking about how he like
strong arms and manipulates women into
like working with him right that's a
good insight
Ethan although I don't think Aiden would
come because um he already
like we we tried like a month ago
remember and he like ghosted you well we
right I I I'm gonna try again and he
doesn't have to say it but maybe he
wants to promote his new uh gambling
website
kick yeah maybe
um
yeah so that's fun hey speaking of new
Alphas
you guys know how uh there's cart nark
out there who's causing mischief
he recently had a gun pulled on him
y'all remember that and he was just like
no I'm not scared of you I do remember
that this man was willing to die for the
game
died for the cause here's a new one
another new insane carton this man is
still out there
brother you are impossibly too committed
you know
can we scale it back a little bit
lazy bones the lazy
so check this out dude this shit's crazy
man how big your [__] ass sir I
was told
Italy moment
the tip
sir I was told to give it to you get the
[__] out of here oh boy that was awesome
yeah it was good
I feel it really
in a sense it really highlights how
crazy
people really are I mean there's so many
crazy people out there and they're just
walking amongst us this man
is like a magnet what I don't get is you
could just drive off just leave just
leave that man is on the road somewhere
oh yeah right now
if he's not already died of a heart
attack that brain is behind a wheel oh
yeah [__] answer I was told
he's so angry he's got a big ass fanny
pack I was about to say what's like the
utility bag he's got there he's just a
weird guy he's got all kinds of she's up
to all kinds that's a big ass fanny pack
he's got a lot of gadgets right
he's Fearless
that's true
cardinal is kind of the craziest of all
them this man ain't [__] like hard yeah
and then he doesn't even slow down he
doesn't say he doesn't laugh he doesn't
say he just goes right back at him
sir I was told to give it to you
oh man Walmart's a hell of a store isn't
it
wait here's a video of um I didn't find
the original but I feel like isn't this
the same guy card knock yeah that's her
boy who caught in the show no he got he
got attacked by the same guy twice I
think
that's why no I sent you another link no
that's not him let me see
wait you got you sent me a link of xqc
reactions I didn't find the original bro
what the [__]
what is wrong is it the same car
dude he's so annoying
now sir oh [__] he upgraded to a big ass
flag
dude he's so out of control
where the cards Go sir
well you should because it's a different
guy
what is the sign it sounds different
he does have a big ass fanny pack though
turn cards here
he's a weird dude but he's got that
actually I think this is a shirt of
himself that he looks like him with the
hat and everything right yeah I think
this guy was a famous guy or something
yeah that's Perry uh caravello or
something he's famous yeah yeah yeah
there's the Howard Stern guy he was
talking about when he came on the show
wait are you serious I think Stern
messed with him too or something cart
mark was talking about it when he was on
the show since I placed return cards
there and you're gonna put magnet a
shame sir
whoa
stop it excusing
let's just watch actually I think that
is the same guy
in the same car I just took screenshots
what are the odds he got found him again
that's what I'm saying so here okay so
this was the guy who was a subject of a
fake documentary
here we've we've compound both he's got
the Italian shirt and the hat this is
the dude that drives around La with his
name on the car Dan if you know what I'm
talking about so wait I don't know no
okay wait fine let me get a screenshot
of the original one
the one that we just watched to compare
a character
okay what was the name of the
documentary they made about this guy
I think Jimmy Kimmel and some friends
told this guy he was like famous
they convinced him he's famous and they
did a whole pseudo documentary it's
really [__] up
and he still hasn't recovered apparently
now sir
well so do we think this guy's just a
nut or does that call into question he's
a nut okay he's he's a nut so it's not
that these videos like carton aren't
faked the videos I would I would never
accuse him of that and I don't think he
did that okay it is interesting though
hmm that he's run into the same guy
twice maybe someone's tipping him off
so he could harass him here here he is
again the lazy bones The Fanny fast same
shirt
that one
no it's not different shirt he's got
multiple it is an Italian flag on
multiple Italian flags
[__] that's crazy interesting well we
gotta do we are we gonna get a hold of
cartonark and ask him about this because
this follows a lot into question it
really does
a lot of people in the chat are
hmm
are we public sentiment is uh turning
against carton our care well they he
didn't really have him the first time
right now there's just this Great Divide
you know there's a fight okay this is
important whoever's in touch with carton
Arc we need to
get to the bottom of this
Zach were you speaking with them if I
recall I believe I have to go look
through my email okay
turn your cart
would you like a magnet instead dude
this man has one of these things
what do you remember this [__] my
grandma oh the club the club the club
right is that what it was called steal
their car yeah
so stupid those were like all the rage
for a minute what what's the guy's first
name I'm sorry Perry
[__] [__]
as soon as you take your cards
Jesus Christ
look at yourself yeah we should really
be focusing on xqc's reaction yeah which
is super genuine let's check it out
who's Perry Carabella live Ross fell off
look sir when a rock doesn't get Max
when sir I'll give you two because
you're being such an angry bones where's
that
this guy is so angry he's getting
double magnets
in the flag
watch out behind you sir
uh-huh what a jerk face
please be careful don't be a I can't
hear you
he's in
oh sir
why'd you just take your card back
oh this is falling off
my [__] [__] car as soon as you
push your car back sorry guys [__]
yourself now sir they pay employees
oh you are how old are you sir what was
that sir like a sub notification
interestingly I would say ours is fair
use and his is not
see we're making a parody of his
reaction he is not doing anything to
transform cart in our content
I just want to give you guys a little
lesson here on fair use
see this this is the face of someone
breaking the law right now he's he's the
juice man he's a criminal this is a face
of a criminal he's a good man I'm team
xqc I'm with love I'm also team xqc well
because you met him one time you spent
every day with me
yeah yeah
I met him once almost worked out with
him once right he didn't like on you but
so we're pretty much best friends yeah
so you're friends with a Criminal
wow hanging out with a felon perhaps
perhaps
all right cart and Arc worry we have
questions we need answers I just emailed
them thank you
um let's see we got a whole bunch to get
through today
Dan has officially lost it hmm
me that's what it says oh Dad Dad
[Music]
just call me dad again
no I said no I saw the word no I called
Dad Dan yeah but what what just happened
is you looked at the screen saw the word
dad and we're like Dan no but it's the
opposite of what you accuse me okay
commutative property it goes with ways
this isn't math you see Dad you think
about Dan
and that's special yes okay Dad all
right you're be my dad please Dad
I'm the cool dad now I'll be the cool
dad get over here it's not gonna be that
kind of cool dad come here Daddy not
that cool I got needs over here Dad no
no no
no no no so what is this uh dad is this
is what he calls content is this what it
is Maybe
yeah I think he like said my name like
1200 times or something that's it I
don't I don't even know he's be he's
having beef with himself at this point
okay first of all Dad if you're gonna do
one of these I'm gonna say this thing a
billion times challenge first of all a b
is like the easiest word to say so you
need to get even higher numbers okay Mr
Beast used to do this and he'd say at
what like a hundred thousand times he'd
sit there for like seven days straight
and this is rookie [__] Ababa you do
like the he did like the entirety of
Jake Paul's song
you know listening to it right 24 hours
yeah like a whole song like commits is
just one name Dad commit
I don't even know what's going on
there's a whole beef I'm not a part of
people are commenting on my posts like
uh dead is gonna beat you in the
subathon I'm like what are you talking
about there's no I didn't even know that
my myself excuse me a sub-a-thon you got
[__] home this man gets like one
message every 30 seconds and you know
okay sorry maybe I'm being right there
what is BGN what currency is that
um BGN uh
that is a good sound bite
Bulgarian uh Lev how much is 100
bulgarians
one one Bulgarian Lev is uh 55 cents so
that's a pretty generous tip it's that's
like it's like 55 bucks nice I guess
beautiful
get any tips that big Reese from The Av
oh yeah
big tips I think I think it's sort of
backfiring his whole plan because people
think there's some kind of competition
and then oh that's funny yeah people
just come in and giving your ass money
thanks to Dad I'm dick tips well that's
I mean
keep the beef up then yeah whatever
whatever dad just yeah yeah whatever
he's doing go for it I love that sound
bite though
that's good stunning actually it's
stunning that's nice John Johnson said
uh hi my name is Christian Klein okay
sorry
what this is so confusing it says John
Johnson says my name is Christian Klein
left by Frankie
am I confused no Frank is the next
mission
yeah Frankie's unrelated I've been
watching Ethan since before the podcast
and you helped me through some hard
times thanks bro don't Tell Sebastian
that
I only count people that come crime
bawling to me in public
as people who have saved it's my
birthday can I get a character I'm 26.
[__] you
yeah so I'm just saying that if you want
to do something impressive saying Logan
Paul a hundred thousand times Logan Paul
that's like a b is practically one
syllable
I think it's technically two but it's
just you can really squeeze them
together yeah I agree
so maybe it's a matter of how long it
takes to say a b right Logan Paul like
that takes that's a whole mouthful Logan
Paul Logan Paul Logan Paul Logan Paul
that's 50 more syllables yeah all right
okay so I'm saying he did that a hundred
thousand times Dad okay whatever not
impressed
all right well the pressure's on
we should start a donation war with
Hassan
oh yeah dang well then he's got to start
it because then everyone's just going to
go give him money
all right well they can start with us
they're like damn donation War guys this
donation war between really heating up
they're talking [__]
oh so somebody uh thank you Derek run
said this one is for ababab thank you
Derek maybe maybe maybe
stop it does sound like Mongolian throat
singing
hey guys I've got some good news oh yeah
um as you guys
know the growing threat of anti-Semitism
is real
and
it affects all of us but mostly me it
affects me in particular personally yeah
and uh Kanye West has been one of the
biggest spreaders of anti-Semitism but
we've had a breakthrough actually one of
our best and brightest
uh was sent to intervene
that's right Kanye West has finally
somebody got through to him he posted on
Instagram
watching Jonah Hill and 21 Jump Street
made me like Jewish people again
[Laughter]
and I was thinking to myself well if
it's like a matter of chubby hairy
curly-haired Jews that he might he might
like me as well
interesting good point
you know
then he goes on no one should take anger
against one or two individuals and
transform that into hatred towards
millions of innocent people no [__]
dummy
[Music]
I still feel like he's just being a
piece of [__] mocking like he's just
being super facetious about it yeah I
think that's the disturbing part about
it
he says uh no Christian can label well
then he goes on to be like well actually
just kidding I'm not I can't be
anti-semitic because we're the real Jews
no Christian can be labeled anti-semite
knowing Jesus is Jew
thank you Jonah Hill I love you
[Laughter]
thank you for your performance my friend
so that's kind of a in this like 10 year
old comedy yeah you know
the only thing getting blown Tonight is
their cover that's the slogan
that's pretty bad that is pretty bad
they actually wrote that [__] down on
the cover
holy [__] dude
the only thing getting blown tonight
oh they go way back is channum Tatum's
giant [__] oh so they're homies how can
you say that bro
that's not cool
well get try to get through to your
homie Nick Fuentes who basically is
ready to do another genocide on us kids
loved him
Hitler that's him by the way
all right but that's good news
somebody said imagine if Hitler saw
super bad so true God so many
so many great people would have been
saved oh this is great only
Kanye West against the Jews after he
watches Jonah Hill and 21 Jump Street
[Music]
all right but it's not well right but
it's the other way around in it like I
believe Jonah would be Michael in this
situation okay okay Kanye would be
holding the gun okay to the Jews that's
powerful and Jonah Hill said please put
that down Michael can't even Michael's
like laughing and so silly look at him
he's like this is dumb
and then he and then he was like damn I
hope little Timmy is ready for tonight
because
I need to unwind
I got uh big plans at Neverland Ranch
the cotton candy machine
just got the roller coaster
maintained and oh oh yeah I just uh
installed my new alarm system throughout
my hallway so that I know if anyone's
approaching my door anywhere in the
house
uh before you do that why don't you just
have a seat
hey sorry I don't I know I always turn
this on UAB I don't do it consciously
because I know because I just know
you're a Michael Jackson fan
but I always go like uh maybe but you
don't you you don't believe he was
innocent dude I know I've asked you this
like a thousand times but you say like
you're kind of half half or you think he
did it or
I think where are we that when you have
a platform such as this you should not
speculate on these things because it
makes other victims afraid to come out
and I'm not saying that sarcastically
um what yeah that's that's what I'm
saying I feel like I you shouldn't
speculate on these things because it
invalidates other people how
how does me saying Michael Jackson you
saying that doesn't do anything but
you're asking me that
whoa whoa
whoa
did Michael Jackson touch you
what
you're not there you're we're not making
any accusations I don't understand your
point
you know there's a poll on Reddit the
other day and I said who's your least
favorite crew member and it was me
seriously and I wonder why and then I'm
like oh no I know why wait was it really
huh what kind of poll was that I never
that's [__] up the best kind that
can't be true that didn't happen I swear
to God
that's [__] up I'm sorry it's all good
Banda [__]
but I never want to vote did it have a
lot of votes it didn't have
well we'll send the link at least
okay I want to see
the results well you know I would be
last
you know if they really voted you would
be last I think so
no I think you're misunderstanding the
poll the poll was which cast member does
do you like the lease oh oh oh oh oh
yeah not the audience not the audience
no no it was the audience no I said
who's your least favorite or
well me in the audience would be aligned
on that one though I'm just kidding it'd
be you know I love you but that's [__]
up we shouldn't allow polls like that
but I do want to link curious
it shouldn't allow it but I'm very
curious to see the results
I thought people people love UAB and
that's not true oh yeah it's it I know
it's Reddit you're a fighter
it's not your fault I'm not worried
about you're funny you're great at your
job it's not your fault
it's not your fault no but I don't think
that's true what did it have like 10
votes
I don't know I don't know it had 89 000
votes seriously I was like what the [__]
you you've brought us the burrito
so true the Bongos the bongos
so many great moments BTS almost dying
BTS B does the BTS you guys like that
[__] no respect save that child from a
burning car it's true you guys don't
even want to know what I did yesterday
you guys won't even believe it tell me
wait what's up the old man
people in chat are telling me to talk
about it but I was like let's hear it go
ahead
there was old man he was lost he had
dementia
and he was going like door to door and
no one was helping him
and uh I helped him but nobody would
help him but you know no way a b helped
him
yeah AV had the courage
and the care
to stand against the whole world this
great Injustice and say no I
have witnesses I will anyone but Lena
yep I was on stream when it happened
you know because I helped him off camera
just out of frame over here
oh wait hold on oh wait hold on there's
a deal with dementia are you okay wait
okay
you find your home
hold on one sec guys
I think he needs help
[Music]
oh he's taken care of
hero AB everyone
[Applause]
actually you know what Sam can we get a
trophy for ab
[Laughter]
by he saved the senile man on stream
off well uh not on stream but to stream
adjacent
and then let me ask you this what if I
said I did have footage of it then
what's the next what's the next response
I want I would say give it to myself
you guys would say you recorded it what
a clout Goblin no was it just like you
see the proof home security camera or
something
I didn't say I do have but if I did have
I want to see the proof
he said if
meaning uh Lola said hi
I run a woman-owned and operated Bakery
in La called chocolate
chocolate in the chip oh my God
struggling in the chip she says I want
to send you you know I want to try I
can't wait to try your bakery
reach out to one of the guys
get some cookies the architect says as
an avid AB supporter I will confirm that
he left Midstream to help this poor old
guy he's a great dude and we'll catch
this fat W against dad
thank you he's trustworthy
I'm sure if you talked about the
incident at Nashville but shout out to
the crew and Ethan for making me laugh
today I work and live within walking
distance of this school what happened
wait what happened there was another
school shooting this morning today
um
what school was it what what level
Elementary School
hey
and and
well give me the details now I want to
know uh it was a 20 year old 28 year old
uh woman was the shooter oh that's a
rare uh W for the rare uh
dub for the ladies
uh and yes uh I believe three kids and
three adults dead so far what a [__]
what the [__] bro I can't get over the
fact that like dead kids they just don't
care they don't care
I was watching a true crime uh
uh episode yesterday
JCS criminal psychology you guys
probably know that they're famous yeah
fantastic it's been The Meta to react to
those I keep seeing it pop up on various
their videos are so good they're the
best I've watched all of them but there
was one episode
where this dude had a gun
and he was arguing he was being a
dumbass like a family was parked in the
handicapped spot but the the parking lot
was basically open there was tons of
parking everywhere
and so the guy is basically harassing
the mom and kids being like yo where's
your handicap placard whatever being
like really really aggressive they were
black by the way the family and he's
like some yeehaw
and the dad comes out and sees him
yelling at his wife and he shoves him
over and so this guy pulls out a gun
the dad backs up he puts his hands up
and he backs up he's walking away from
him the dude Waits two seconds and then
he shoots and kills him in front of his
family Jesus and I was thinking to
myself
you know this saying is Right more guns
is more safe I really do believe that
after seeing that like this guy thinks
he's a [__] Cowboy and he's walking
around with a gun and not only that this
guy apparently has a history of pulling
his gun out and confrontations in his
car it's happened like six times so yeah
more guns more safe I think it's just
obvious
it's obvious
it's actually quite it's quite
incredible that they've convinced so
many people the gun lobbyists
that more guns is more safe I mean
that's like that's like saying you know
more water I saw yeah I don't know it's
psychotic it's like
more calories is less calories
yeah it's [__] up and disgusting [__]
it makes me angry
why did there there's no other details
about it no it happened just very short
like before it happened this morning
like an hour or two before we went live
it's kind of a developing thing
so how many is that this year eh
I I'm not sure
thousand
many school shootings in 2023 so far
and I'm proud to be an American where
children are killed in school
and the answer is to put guns to
teachers
what is this picture
oh is that the guy you saved that is I
do have a video yo this is the dude
they'd be saved I just don't want to
play because I want to dox myself but I
do here's a screenshot look at this [__]
bro he sent me this [__] can you guys
reverse image search this go ahead this
is him huh as him hmm
and he was like oh where am I where am I
it was on board I believe it said yeah
he he parked in the wrong structure too
oh no and I had to go with the nurses to
go find his car so what happened you
call 9-1-1 no I I helped him
um because I know there's a place a few
buildings away from me that uh he may
have been living in so I walked I walked
him and it took [__] forever it took
me about probably 30 minutes to just
walk him that far and he couldn't
remember where his car was so we got
there and then I went with the nurses to
help him find his uh car yeah it
reminded me of my grandma because she
she has dementia so I kind of was
familiar with uh the signs um what a guy
that's very sweet of you
thank you thank you this is AB saving uh
a man with dementia actually
[Applause]
[Music]
somehow
I'm not sure as well put it down
it was so funny put it down well that's
nice you just got some good car maybe we
need to influence that poll
if anyone has it send it so we can
influence it do we not find it
I never got a link to it
[Music]
uh becoming a member by the way because
Ethan has done JCS react to see you next
Tuesday
I did yeah
you spent like one of like a whole
episode like a month ago reacting to one
of those videos
I don't remember
somehow
um
so let's keep it going let's not get to
uh let's keep it going let's have a lot
fun light episode let's not get too
caught up here okay this is out of
pocket now I feel like I just looked at
my sister's [__] this is [__] up
I'm like Aiden Ross being like no you
guys took it too far
[Laughter]
it's my dad wandering the streets of Los
Angeles stabbing beach balls he'll be
dangerous he'll start stabbing people
seeing beach balls
dad
here's my Dan
thank you oh I see you
actually there was a huge crash on the
freeway everyone's okay though
um a b was not involved in this crash to
my knowledge he filmed it
he's the tire
okay
all right
everyone's cruising along here seems all
good oh my God whoa
how the [__] whoa
dude how do you even process that yeah
if you're in that car out of nowhere you
just launched 20 feet in the air this is
wild because this is right by my old
house like I would get off the freeway
right there on that exit yeah so
everyone's okay so don't worry it's
[__] wild dude this man just lost a
foreign
by the way shout out to these card
morons who like he's like I'm gonna
modify my truck so the wheels stick out
and then crash cut to later that
afternoon
I'm gonna stick up I want my wheels to
stick out it's badass
good ad for uh though yeah dude seat
belts seconds the guy was just like oh
my God I'm flying and then and then I
can't fly I don't I don't think you can
think in that time like I'm sure it just
happens so quickly you're like oh [__]
yeah I'm sure
this is crazy
the wheels that's why I love America
only in America huh yeah today we're
gonna stick on our wheels so it looks
sick this isn't only an America thing
a truck a pickup truck with wheels that
stick out like 10 inches
yeah where else do they do that maybe
that where else would they do this dumb
[__] this man didn't tighten his [__]
wheel on enough and just went driving
only in Kansas City
dude America is such a stupid place
I bought an American car this weekend
really yeah massive juicer American
brother car wait what'd you get a
Lincoln Navigator okay
wait say how much again
how much did you pay for it three
thousand three hundred dollars okay that
that makes sense love you said it's got
some ponies under the hood huh dude like
330 juice from a goose or horsepower
so this is a huge car is why 2000 this
is why I asked why because it's so
massive it's a 2000 car
yeah if you're right 2000 they're awake
right right 2 000 with big ass rims
you have big rims I bought it because it
was so
wild it's a good price you got on it
although how many miles does it have it
looks like the one on the right on the
top right
oh my God yeah
oh that's sick I'm good I'm glad what
happened to the old tester mobile did it
break down is it done yeah it's
completely messed up uh but yeah how
does it feel to be in a big ass car dude
it's so fun I feel like it can murder a
whole family you know
foreign
that's how I feel man it's like if it's
got to be me or them it's definitely
going to be them if I'm in this car yeah
I in Europe the parking spots are so
tight so I can't park anywhere yeah I
was gonna say I had to walk five minutes
to the mall today
wait is that car a spectacle there in
Sweden because yeah it's probably
unusual right anyway it's important too
they don't sell the mirror that's still
interesting that you found it yeah
I gotta watch this again
he's like I'll be on my way he's like
well
I'll be on my way it just look gloss me
a tire
our kids uh do they have a good
reputation for safety no they don't
huh cause I'm very impressed that they
walked away from this accident I gotta
say
bro this is crazy
[Music]
that's that out that car Ikea's Alpha is
[__] for real
ready for anything it is a shame for
your kid not to be tossed 20 feet in the
air to see how durable it is
Aristotle
okay that was [__] nuts man the world
is crazy real
the crazy world out there people
we're all just living in it mm-hmm
not easy
sneako his bot is doing boxing
something like that that's one way of
putting it I thought he would just sit
in the corner and watch uh no he would
actually get in the room it would have
been an improvement
so let's see how he does this guy's been
talking a lot of [__] about like being
able to beat people up let's see
is he moving in slo-mo what's my
immediate reaction as well wait is this
is this video on slow-mo what's going on
here it's at half speed
can you guys send me the link where it's
a normal speaker I think he's training
underwater he's like resistance right
now bud
holy [__]
now listen I'm not a fighter I know if I
got in the ring I wouldn't look better
okay but I'm not getting in the ring and
I'm not talking [__] I don't know you
and you and Oliver tree uh like play
fighting is more violent to me than what
I'm witnessing right now okay I'll take
it I'll take that
get him again foreign
you know if this wasn't boxing You Close
Your Eyes it sounds like a like a
cuckold
Let Me Close My Eyes in Magic there you
go you hit him good job do it again
what do you take on this baby
I don't I don't know what kind of gym
would allow any characters to fight
without any protective gear oh really
yeah kind of a bad form there for for
them
he knows he's like man this [__]
nobody's getting hurt
it's like bumper cars
yeah well I'd love to keep watching this
but I actually uh have a to entertain uh
people so gonna move on from that
he's sparring in Japan apparently so
good luck to him he'll be a prize
fighter in no time
is all about the
so this guy uh Jesse Lee Peterson he is
so [__] crazy and I love him he is a
talk show host Ultra conservative
fans of the show have seen me talking
about him but he is what he's super
homophobic he's like he says he's an
alpha male he loves that whole alpha
male [__]
[Music]
and he also has really funny things
about him like he goes real men do this
real men do that this man actually left
his child fatherless uh completely
abandoned his family
now that's pretty beta where I come from
and I am the king of alpha so you should
listen to me no
do you regret not getting married having
children not at your older
well and I'm gay you're gay yes you all
okay
I did he said you don't look at it I
find him so entertaining I mean he's
just so unique and [__] crazy
we come in all shapes and sizes brother
so you okay I'm gay I didn't know you
were gay yeah that's all I just told you
you become gay how did you become gay
oh [__] this man thinks the ashes that
nobody would dream of come gay one is
born that way does God know you're gay I
believe so did he make you that way I
that's my opinion you think that God
Made You Gay I have no you know I don't
I don't know the I'm not going to be
presumed to uh uh just say yes bro you
know
Plumb the depths of the of the most high
but yes I've I've been gay as long as I
can remember and so have you been with
men of course like sexually yes really
yes that's my role
I've I've sometimes thought about going
on a show because he's interviewed
Hassan and um
David Pacman and other people I like and
it's just so funny man
he asked the craziest question
amazing he always says that
so there you go
but it's an example that somebody who's
playing it all morning and it's it's so
weird
I didn't know you were gay
you okay that is some great sound bites
you okay does God know you're gay I
didn't know you were gay really that's
my mind I mean who would think to ask
that does God know you're gay
you think that God Made You Gay what
he's like yeah he's unaware God doesn't
know that yeah we haven't broken the
news yeah so have you been with men
you should just do that
yeah
what do you think Dan do you think I
should reach out to him
I mean what do you have to lose right
apparently this guy is uh lost quite a
bit of clout in the manosphere world
though because wouldn't you know it I
didn't know about this until this
morning uh cam mentioned it but a bunch
of his
former collaborators and people that
worked with him or whatever
all came out and said that
he's gay
has he told Cod
has he does God know wait okay
so again I can't get over it the
manosphere is leaving this guy because
he's gay not because he's like a total
[__] bag who abandoned his children has
no coherent values
but because he's attracted to men we
don't want him yeah and I mean obviously
it's a little ironic considering how
homophobic he is and how much he talks
about how his homophobia David Pacman
has come out after the fact too and said
that he was handsy with him uh really
dancing with David I don't know to what
degree but he said he was handsy with
him in the studio we gotta for some
reason I feel like he will get along
with the Siemens another type of milk
okay
because he also says they're both
positive yet he loves to drink semen
right they're both religious
well I think it's great that he's gay
you okay
I'm not you okay
no I'm not I didn't know you were gay
well I'm not I know you're gay not
there's anything wrong with that what
does God know you're gay
that's why he's unaware he's unaware I
think he thinks that God abandoned
the gay person that's why he's saying
that does God know
does God know you're gay
Texas Texas thank you for the 10 gift
appreciate you Stephen says thank you
for all you do your podcast helped me
keep me alive the past five years
working deep sea in the offshore
industry whoa that sounds Alpha [__] I
recently retired him and moving to La
this Friday pursue stand-up comedy oh my
God would love to snag the next
internship wait how much life have you
lived brother
this man was deep sea offshore for five
years now he's coming to do comedy
you better write some jokes about the
bottom of the sea
I'm curious
um from what I understand the people
that do that are paid extremely well
oh because who else would do that [__]
super Dame it's like is it doesn't it
rank like the most dangerous job or it's
like in the top
couple that number one police officer
Dan what are you talking about I
remember when we were researching uh
chemical compression diving compression
and uh what it is is
these guys go to the bottom of the
[__] ocean and work on the oil pipes
and the internet lines and all that kind
of stuff on the bottom and they have to
slowly submerge to the bottom of the
ocean and then sleep there for a few
days as their body pressure uh equalizes
to the bottom of the ocean
and this to me is the craziest part on
the bottom of the ocean they put on a
[__] suit and they just go out into
the vast [__] empty darkness of the
ocean they go out there's like a little
hole they're in a pod and then there's
like a little hole that's open all the
time that they just go into the water
they just go into the water Pitch Black
it's wild
I'm seeing Derek operators in oil gas
and Mining is the third most deadly job
in the United States I don't I that
sounds more broad though I have to
imagine the people that do that is is
probably statistically even higher
because yeah that's it's crazy what they
do I found a clip of someone who was a
compression diver talking about how you
went diving once and saw a giant eye
looking back at him can you try to find
that what yeah
yeah scary someone asked him what was
the scariest thing that ever happened to
you compression diving
I actually
um you know I was thinking that it's
such a fun concept for a horror thriller
movie about compression divers I wrote a
movie script with chat gbt at home
you know there's some movie what's the
movie like the giant shark not just
no there's a newer one with like a mega
shark or whatever it's called
the room uh guys maybe whatever it is
I'm sure it's not good based on that
description
it's called it's called
how do you pronounce it no you said it
right I just thought it was fine because
you put the apostrophe the the trench uh
they
they go that that deep no they don't go
to the trench
the
the saturation divers yeah yeah no they
don't go in the Mariana Trench why would
they do that well how deep down do they
go well it's like the it's like the
general uh length of the Atlantic Ocean
for example whatever the average length
this you know the depth of the app the
Atlantic Ocean
antic ocean average depth because the
Mariana Trench is like a very specific
place that just goes all the way down
right Gino James Cameron took that
[__] machine and went to the bottom
there you know yeah but they don't have
like Wi-Fi they don't have right right
right they don't have fiber optics going
to the bottom that I know of
um so they're going down like three ten
thousand feet
yeah
wow
yeah so here's the plot of my movie tell
me what you think
so this is as far as I've gotten tell me
if you think this is his potential so
you got these two saturation drivers
divers
one of them's experienced
one of them's a rookie
two of them they go down in two
sometimes threes
I'm I'm tearing this down to the bare
minimum here just for you guys taking
all the background stuff out they go
down
they're down at the bottom
they're taking their time they're doing
the saturation equalizing their body
pressure
and so the rookie guy goes out the first
night or the third night or whatever
does this shift
and I gotta tell you they're out in the
middle of the ocean with like a little
blowtor or like a welder underwater
Welding Tool
so you can see flashes of like uh Sparks
of light and electricity and and
otherwise completely dead dark Zone
so he does a shift
the experienced guy hears something
Clank something went wrong he hears
yelling on the radio so he goes down
there he saves
because of inexperience this guy got
into some trouble either the welder
messed up or
he's he got a leak on his oxygen or
something but he brings him back and
everything's fine
then he does his shift everything goes
good he's a he's the veteran
but then the next day the rookie goes
out again to do a shift
but this time
each shift is two hours he doesn't come
back from his shift
the veteran goes out there to look for
him
he's not he's gone he's just gone
bottom of the ocean Darkness
there's no trace of him he's gone
boys did I miss the sun everyone's gone
now
that's all I have
I have a few other ideas I'm just not
sure you know it could be like an
underwater uh Alien civilization that's
just the abyss
right okay so we're not gonna go that
route but I was really I was thinking
more like Blair Witch Project type of
just like uh just like the visuals and
the horror of just not seeing stuff you
know that kind of angle
just the unknown
that's a good that's a scary premise
though right
yeah I mean it's scary underwater
okay
I'm not totally sold yet okay I'm gonna
be honest a little bit it needs work it
needs work yeah I hate going in the
ocean the characters feel a little flat
to me I mean rookie I mean what are
their names who are they about I know I
get it I'm not the surface do they have
a wife a girlfriend yes yes but I do not
I'm just trying to tell you the premise
that they find the Titanic no no you
need some tokun in there throw some yeah
there's an avatar the stink lack of toon
Coons okay so then there's blue
creatures I agree with that yeah I think
that there is a a good amount of toon
[__] happening and that's too much
already what is the talking whale that's
the big whales I haven't even seen
Avatar 2 yet
okay then at the bottom there's like
these blue creatures that want they just
want to wrap their little tendrils
around them and that's their way of
having sex is there a sex scene in this
movie there would be yes they find love
they'll just be a joke he'll be a jerk
off scene he's alone and he just jerks
off he's jerks off underwater just sad
and you're stressed out no in his little
in his uh habitat it's a it's a
flashback moment he remembers his life
on land he's like I miss my friend I'm
gonna go beat off like yep what if the
divers fell in love with each other
little brokeback uh Mountain type of
thing where they or only be them true
selves in the Pod that's kind of a fire
angle
from the ocean brokeback trench
so they're only lovers but then maybe
something goes wrong maybe he cheats he
[__] one of the blue aliens one of the
fish infidelity [__] a fish this is
where they live
this is where they live damn and then on
this side there's just a hole that goes
into the ocean it is a good setting
unironically that is a good setting for
a horror movie though thank you that's
all I'm saying yeah I now you do the
hard part not gonna hire a writer like
you do the rest flush it out create and
put characters good dialogue
[Music]
exactly
so here's this guy talking about it this
is the clip that made me like think
about this movie premise which whatever
but listen it went down
and I opened my eyes in my in my let me
just go back a bit to the question
uh whatever the abyss all those scary
movies right and you think about all
this
things that could be down there can't
help but going through your head so it's
kind of freaky
and then you finish and you put your
mask back on
and I took a big breath
and I went down
and I opened my eyes in my in my mask in
the darkness with my flashlight and I
saw like right in front of me this huge
eyeball
like
about the size hold on hold on hold on
hold on what was that Joe
uh what what was that he's providing
visual ways
okay whatever y'all saw the funny face
you know like this pic
staring unblinking right at me
and I freaked out I just tore off for
them for the pool for the moon pool and
the habitat I jumped in there I surfaced
I'm screaming I'm screaming and my crew
come running at the guy like I've been
bit by a shark or something
and I'm like giant fish and it wasn't it
was a goliath grouper oh I've seen those
things before they're enormous size of a
cow I think I would die I think I would
die of fear in that moment a Goliath any
fish that starts with Goliath is not
good
Goliath group they're really creepy
oh [__] hell any fish bigger than us is
too much look how big these things are
so he goes down and he just sees a big
ass eye right in front of him that's it
you know rod and car Polk you could
write that right into the horror film
there's a scene boom
done
next movie
on to the sequel any screenplay any
screenwriters want to write that for me
and put my name on it email me
underwater thrill horror movie that
takes place in the deep sea inside one
of those cramped tube livings that's
that was my idea Shelby
oh underwater is a thriller
oh it already exists yeah I've seen it
oh no [__]
you've seen it is it good
or maybe it's not that one but it has TJ
Miller you know that movie sucks then
they [__] made a underwater movie
with TJ Miller
why does it lie hell nah foreign
film
underwater Falls a group of workers on a
drilling facility at the bottom of the
ocean encounter hostile creatures from
an earthquake oh god oh I have seen
another one that's a bang [__] bang
these guys stole my idea except I'll
make it without TJ Miller would be way
better
you know
the voice is underwater when they're in
those tubes they change and they're
super squeaky it's pretty funny it's on
the video
that's what they sound like yeah
[__] live and sound like that
yeah
that's not very scary at all
that's embarrassing cringe cringe
canceled
I was gonna say these guys are alpha but
it's kind of beta
wait wait hold the [__] phone they
all sound like this the whole time
why would they sound like that I don't I
don't quite get it
because I think they they mix the air
with some kind of another gas to
to make it not like
[Music]
everything else
I don't believe this because regular air
is toxic at high pressures deep sea
divers live on a mix of helium and
oxygen no meaning they live and speak
with squeaky helium voices for around a
month while working
that's me
I think I would go crazy hearing
everything like that
yeah so whatever these guys were saying
they make a lot of money it's not enough
I think they make like 180 000 a year or
something
fascinating holy [__] oh
here's a little preview of what your
deep sea creature could look like
I come out of the pool what do I see
the eye of a man who's on DMT
who's just come out of a deprivation
tank for five days 30 men go in the
water
I can't believe this this is not funny
or scary I mean this is not scary and
you know I'd have to do my movie Super
realistic so they'd have to tell me
that would actually kind of rock to do a
horror movie that's played totally
straight
but to keep it realistic all of the all
the actors are just bed helium or green
helium that's amazing
yeah they make a 150 to 180 but I guess
they only work for like a couple months
per year so
still [__] that yeah yeah
and you gotta sound like a chipmunk
well there that is you know compelling
stuff interesting stuff cool stuff slick
stuff cleats
mm-hmm
uh do you guys I'm like I'm starving
Bubba I don't know why I've been doing
my new
um breakfast routine and I eat a lot
I have what are you hidden two percent
yogurt two full cups Greek yogurt Zack
oh yeah ton of mixed berries I'm talking
blueberries blackberries raspberries
strawberries nice and then a bunch of
nuts I'm talking pistachios almonds
walnuts cashews these nuts pretty girl
nuts pretty girl pretty girl nuts I'm
trying to engineer the perfect
healthiest breakfast and for what I've
understood
this is
the perfect breakfast chocolate mocha
that being said CREAM yeah they're all
different I'm ready to eat a whole pizza
at this moment so you do the math
I am starving though you guys you guys
hungry
Steven said I graduated from uh Maine
Maritime Academy since then I've been
sailing deep sea experiencing some
insane things hundreds of miles from
Land too far for any help or helicopter
to come save you in anything were to go
wrong I made 400 a day is that good or
bad that sounds like not enough
it seems like not enough for how
dangerous that is he's like I could die
at any second nobody would hear me
scream or find my body I paid I got 400
a day
well what would that come out to if you
go for a month
and those are old days it's decent money
but I just feel like for the danger
level that that does seem low to me 400
a day that's 12 000 a month
that's not enough well that's if he's
going every single day
right like you said it probably happens
in in spurts bro you need to go to you
need to go saturate dive that's the real
deal that's what real men do
so people people say nuts have so much
fat it's healthy fat
nuts are super [__] healthy you guys
got to read the research coming out nuts
like prevent
it's like they prevent like uh senelity
nuts it's crazy like they're finding out
the nuts are
some of the most expensive are healthy
food people that eat nuts and berries
every day
has insane health benefits
well this is good news because those are
both great they are they are both great
it is good news nuts
mm-hmm
and Greek yogurt's really good too so
that's it
thank you
thank you for your listening
I look Jordan Peterson crying don't you
guys
can't get enough it's my favorite genre
videos
here is one a new one
Jordan Peterson describing his discovery
of live music so I don't think it's just
to be clear I don't think either of any
of the footage from this is new is just
somebody this edit went viral
Jordan Peterson describing a discovery
of live music is the most unhinged thing
I've seen from him yet that
says a lot bucko
I'll be the judge of that I've heard
some crazy [__] come out of this
mountain man I went to this bar in
Nashville
wow he's really letting go I just just
you wait
this band was playing Kelly's Heroes a
great guitarist best guitarist I've ever
seen
okay the fact that they have the footage
to corroborate his story is [__]
amazing
oh my God all right I gotta go start
over sorry guys I'm just having so much
fun with this man I went to this bar in
Nashville
[Music]
this band was playing Kelly's Heroes a
great guitarist best guitarist I've ever
seen
[Music]
and they were playing old country music
with a heavy blues rock uh twist so they
do this great version of uh ghost
writers in the sky
[Music]
guitarist just goes way out on limb
and everybody in the crowd it's so it
was so fun to be there they're just
thrilled he's about to cry no he's about
to cry
because they're watching this man doing
the same thing that Surfers do he's like
dancing on the edge of Chaos and Order
it's just live music brother it's not
chaos in order
he's rocking the knife's edge of Chaos
in order
he's Brave He's a brave Warrior
in this virtuosic manner and everyone is
so he's crying taken by that
it just lifts them out of the normality
of their existence you know do you see
this Joy just transfuse them and that's
because they got an intimation of
genuine meaning
[Music]
yes
is that your wife sir
who is that that is
okay this man
his wife no it's not his wife oh I was
gonna say they don't move very well he's
a rascal he's out there flirting is he
not wait why do you think that that's
not his wife that's not his wife she's
like 20 years old what are you talking
about she's a young girl
that he's dancing with I don't think so
wait what no she's an old lady I know
what his wife looks like I may have seen
a picture let me see
oh yeah oh you know what I think it is
it's totally his wife yeah that's my
best well they don't move very well
together
well yeah they're middle-aged white
people we've never let go like this
before so I won't hold it again I love I
love that he's wearing a [__] suit to
a bar oh yeah I really let them know
about the pucks to Joe Rogan the soup to
the bars whatever but the tux on the
podcast is so strange to me and only
knows how to overdress
I've never let go like that before the
music was lifting my spirits in an
almost Sublime way it was the greatest
guitarist I've ever heard
bar band too I mean it's not that
they're I didn't see enough it's not
that they're bad it just looks like
anything you can find on anything in
America yes
he's acting like he's [__]
he's acting like he's Zach Lewis live at
the rock yeah thank you Cameron now that
was something to cry absolutely
get your tickets now right is this the
first concert he's ever been that's what
I'm wondering and I'm wondering if I'm
wondering if keemstar was there having a
beer and two chains came on
acoustic set hey Nashville
[Music]
brother you need to like just have a
life or something I don't know
I've been so busy cleaning my room I
haven't gone outside in 30 years
doing the same thing I like the mental
image of Jordan Peterson just getting
really into like that kind of like into
like rockabilly like he'd just become
like starts dressing like a Rockefeller
guy I love the Stray Cats I mean Brian
Seltzer can really play a mean guitar
that would be a lot better than whatever
he is now man
starts wearing
white teas with cigarette pack rolled up
in the sleeve and red red bandana
hanging out of his back pocket yeah he
sounds like a dead bro he should listen
to Grateful Dead it blow his mind oh my
god get some tabs you know what I mean
imagine the Dead concert I need a shirt
I need a grid of cheese down a chick
down the street
there it is Jordan Peterson living his
best life ladies and gentlemen uh he got
himself out to a live music and it was
the best night of his life
Jordan I [__] hate you and think
you're an idiot but if you want to hear
some better Tunes you know hmm is that
glue slime with the Rocks here he might
die Zach
there was a young man with flowing black
hair he played guitar like a demon
he walked the edge of existence between
chaos and reality both Angel and Demon I
felt my soul stir therefore
he hit the guitar with like all the rage
that the whale the day Pinocchio had hmm
the people were dancing and moving we
all cried in unison
it was the most beautiful moment of my
life I took another Xanax because my
high was coming down
I needed to make sure that I was in the
zone
Zachary Lewis live I took proxy I wanted
to make sure I stayed in the pocket I
took two full Zanny bars I was really
[__] up that day I will be there with
my daughter ripping benzos in The Green
Room what that's awesome have you ever
listened to live musics on Xanax it's a
whole different experience
hmm
then I went to the bathroom and I fell
asleep on the toilet
those things make you sleepy man
I woke up and everyone was gone
just me and my Xanax
and an empty venue
and then I realized
in that empty venue
it was actually my heart that was empty
sober and alone
I started to cry
and I realized the truth of this whole
damn gosh Darkness
I will die I will die alone that's
Auschwitz
I will die and load
hahaha
Christopher beating it over me yeah
right I've never been struck with such
horror
the high of Zach Lewis live at the Roxy
down to the below the another empty
alls of the Roxy no doubt I owe some
apologies for that
I called my wife I said
listen bucko
we need some more Xanax stat I'm having
a consistential crisis
tucking your dick between your legs
I went in the bathroom and I thought I'm
gonna tuck my dick between my legs and
see what it looks like
ouchy that looks pretty good I can't lie
like the way it looked it was
slick
clean
you're the worst shot the [__] I've got
a tight little vagina I tell you all
right all right
I would Jordan
and I want a real man to mount me all
right like Joe Rogan
we'll see who cancels yeah okay I've
gone too far
clearly I've taken it too far
it's the name of the gang but that's the
game that's their hero man that man is
just I don't how is like this
emotionally unstable this man cries over
like stuff you shouldn't cry over that's
a that's like that means he's like
depressed or mentally ill or something
this guy like is a crying watching
Hallmark commercials you know people say
that like when they're depressed they
cry watching like a coffee commercial
about like a happy couple or something
that's him
this man is crying over live music he's
unwell
I need another blood transfusion and
experimental Russian labs
that'll fix me
I fell into a coma and I dreamed of
apple cider swirling around my head
laughing at me tempting me I covered my
mouth and thought no the apple cider
grew closer to my face enveloped my
whole head I shook my head no no no
apple cider I remember taking my
daughter to the playground once when she
was about two a particularly provocative
little monster of about the same age was
standing above her on the same bar she
was gripping I watched him move towards
her eyes locked
he slowly and deliberately stepped on
her hands with increasing force over and
over as he stared me down he knew
exactly what he was doing up yours
Daddy-o that was his philosophy he'd
already concluded that adults were
contemptible and that he could safely
defy them
too bad then that he was destined to
become one
that was the Hopeless future his parents
had saddled him with
to his great and salutary shock I picked
him bodily off the playground structure
and threw him 30 feet down the field
wait 30 feet that's like the length of
our Studio 30 feet down the field that's
what he said this man is literally wrote
into a book the time he attacked a
three-year-old child no
just to be clear fantasize about
attacking oh he's fantasizing shortly
after that sound by he reveals that uh
he did not actually throw the child 30
feet he just wanted to but he was 37
feet of cement potion
he was he he he caught the eye of this
three-year-old and he knew what he was
staring him down like [__] you Daddy-o
if he's calling people Daddio I think
he's got a little rockabilly deep down
inside that he needs to let out
yeah you know actually
um Aiden Ross went off on Friends of
this they're not I think he's just like
not friend of the show brother of the
show Hassan
and I've got to stand up for my boy
Aiden is just gone man pull out I'm kind
of overwatching clips of him but when it
comes to the song I get very but earlier
you were saying should we have him on
it's just like he's just such a dead
meme at this point I don't know
I don't know
I think it might be entertaining to
challenge his ideas but like it's just
gonna be so like pointless you think
the tune is I'll just be like do you
like me tell me the truth yeah I like me
I I remember the was that the first time
he ever came to the show and like just
how
stilted and uncomfortable it all was
because he wouldn't take any of the
questions seriously so here is um here
he is on Hassan
I think he feels alone
uh I think he feels like he made the
wrong choice here and now he's just like
doing everything he can to just maintain
relevance and the only way to maintain
relevance in this regard is by just I
don't need it I don't need relevance I
just signed a [__] multi listen I
don't care
I'm set for life after this year I don't
care I don't like walking outside having
[__] on my dick hey bro talk to
you
hey bro relevance is not the [__]
answer you buffoon you can liberal
relevancy liberal
how about the money you're not doing
this [__] for over to either Hassan
you're doing this [__] for money too you
are okay everything everybody does is
for money we all have jobs we all have
to pay our bills dude
it's interesting there was something
interesting in there
that Aiden was saying he
kind of let slip that it sounds like he
kind of hates being famous
well and he's like I don't care about
that I hate when people come up and talk
to me and he said after this year I'll
be set for life I mean if that's really
true if he's
actually hates this whole game and is
just trying to get a bunch of money and
then disappear off the internet then
I guess more power to him that's what
the kids call copium I believe yeah I
mean yeah he goes I don't want clout
it's like shut up idiot oh you have the
way you have Andrew Tate on your show
every other week
[__] write him love letters
yes
he's doing it for money too that's why
it's over critical you know what he's so
boring
can't even finish it
yo did you guys see this
wait no this isn't real is it hmm this
article
I linked the actual page underneath no
[__] way we did a joke edit y'all saw
the pope um
puffy jacket Pope it wasn't we all found
out it was AI but that puffy jacket was
dripped out and everyone was like yo I
thought it was real at first a lot of
people did I actually even though the
story is funny uh find this whole thing
kind of interesting because I feel like
this is one of the first times I've seen
the vast majority
of people get get one over on them from
uh an AI generated image like this
well and in this case it's kind of I
mean I guess it was a little bit last
week there was those images of trump
getting arrested
um but I feel like those look so goofy
that most people understood it was AI
but this one seemed to get a lot of
people well you know what's interesting
um everyone's like the boys in Brooklyn
dream of having drip that hard and now
where I'm thinking of actually that we
need to make this for Teddy fresh we
posted this
how did they generate this what program
was it mid journey of the journey
probably is that a paid service or um I
think there's a free trial because I
need to [__] get I need I need this
in my life
this AI just [__] made the most hype
ass puffer of all time
the Poke puffer y'all
the puffer fish right the one that turns
into a circle mid Journey okay I'm gonna
get on that
it's insane it just if you look at AI
just one year ago to where it is now
it's like 100 times better than it was
and it's only gonna get better here's
our post we did uh actually did pretty
good 60 000 likes thank you
yo it apparently tricked uh
smell some uh Spanish language news
Outlet no I translated to English it's
it's about that the image is AI and I
guess that we named it probably
oh okay yeah they know they know
why does it lie why does it lie all
right so you guys want to talk about the
um Gwyneth Paltrow [__] the [__] cracks
me up yo that is the trial of the
century but um one of our mods just sent
me just now a
little legal update some huge new can I
get some big news going Zach as a matter
of fact thank you Texas for the 10 gifts
[Music]
oh [__] weights and fish update
weights and fish fishermen pleads guilty
to felony cheating wait felony cheating
that's a real that's a law that you can
bring I thought it'd be like fraud or
something right what is felony cheating
it's pleaded guilty to charges of
cheating and unlawful ownership of wild
animals they just threw that on top
because they're mad they're just mad
and
he's like yo in that uh
uh that peacock you got there that ain't
legal
mm-hmm
The Plea is the first step to teaching
these Crooks to basic life lessons Thou
shalt not steal and crime does not pay
a little bible a little real world
as the yeah so okay uh Brian and komsky
Kaminsky pleaded guilty to one count of
cheating a felony and one count of
unlawful ownership of wild animals just
misdemere I want to know what animal
they had go down a little bit
they also forfeited the boat that they
had used in the competition they'll be
sentenced on May 11th so we'll need live
updates wait forfeited the boat that
they used they took their [__] boat
that's felony cheating brother that's a
big challenge
is that the standard punishment I don't
know I don't know we get your boat now
I've never heard of criminal cheating
they win them both Maybe
no no no that I think maybe they won the
boat in a previous question they also
forfeited the boat that had been used in
the competition that makes it sound like
it's just their Boat Boat
well I'll tell you man you come out here
with that criminal cheating we ain't
take kindly to criminal cheat yeah
confiscate your boat probably take that
boat that was the crime
yo I need more Intel on criminal
cheating
felony yeah uh maybe it's the state
maybe that state has yeah that's some
goofy ass law right there boy they're
cheating
Penal Code Oh California has a penal
code five
uh three two
hmm
criminal fraud see fraud makes sense
three three oh
chaitian let me tell you at law cheating
is a specific criminal fence related to
property
okay whatever
so let's talk about Gwyneth she's being
sued this is the
I think part two of the uh celebrity
trial Bonanza
following on the wake of Johnny Depp
verse uh amber turd Amber turd it's not
really grumpy
comparable to that one it's not but it's
it did start a whole new
genre of content frankly like friend of
the show Emily Baker
has completely blown up on the heels of
the Johnny Depp coverage
but the the details of this case are
quite quite funny I mean with Johnny
Depp at least they were arguing over
something serious
this [__] is dumb as hell let me tell
you man
this happened seven years ago
they crashed into each other on the
bunny slope
so for those of you who don't know what
the bunny slope is it's the beginning
slope for people that have no experience
skiing
it's a very soft
hill and people there are going slow
it's like children and old people and
people whose first time let me show you
bunny slope it's called The Bunny slope
I mean
it kind of says it all in the name in it
in you see this this is what you see on
the bunny slope
right
those kids Roll by the way
and so they crashed on the bunny slope
okay
um this retired guy he was 70 he's 76
now
but this happened seven years ago I was
like yeah dude you were you're old as
[__] no wonder he's like I can't walk
anymore I was like yeah you're 78. old
man
he's like when I when I hit her I could
walk fine yeah you were in your 60s now
you're almost 80 old idiot
it's expected to be an eight day trial
because they crashed into each other on
the bunny slope
it's insane at eight day trial
a lot of ins and outs how could there be
this man's evidence
eight days
Hanukkah the length of Hanukkah
yeah let's get some food I'm starving
I've been exercising you see me I'm on
my grind my Alpha grind right
you guys decide what you want and then
I'll kind of in for the ride it is a
shame to go a whole podcast
without nourishing your muscles in your
body
or broken ribs and a concussion from
Gwyneth Paltrow who weighs 60 pounds
by the way
who ran into him with such velocity as
you can imagine these children are
traveling
they broke four ribs now I'm no fan of
Gwyneth Paltrow but this guy is
definitely a cloud Goblin piece of [__]
uh it's worth pointing out as well that
she is counter suing him and she claims
uh the exact opposite that uh he ran
into her so that is in contention who
who hit who this is an or a trial yeah
no that's why I mean there's a lot
there's a lot of ground I feel like they
really could have just said well that
sucked but I'll okay see you later
be like damn that was crazy we hit each
other okay well see it skiing's kind of
dangerous you know
like you don't have full control of your
body on the snow
people are going fast
or falling or you ever been skiing it's
like it's like a chaos
it is you go downstairs people tumbling
they're falling everywhere there's like
I've been that person oh me too there's
like just a top like a a light orange
plastic net to keep you from falling off
a mountain
that's it and this man got hit by 70
pound Gwyneth Paltrow in the bunny slope
and he's doing an eight day trial over
it
that's America
let's see he's suing her
it's bunny slopes and broken ribs
eight day lawsuits to cover it
you know what a wasted time that is for
the court eight days
of a judge sitting there and a jury
imagine that you as a good God-fearing
citizen of America have to spend eight
days of your life sitting there
listening who [__] hit who on the
skis on the bunny slope
this is
the American Nightmare
but so he's originally sued her for 3
million
the amount was later reduced to 300 000
again this is interesting to me because
I don't know how you could pay your
attorney
okay I think I
this attorney's got to be on a on a
contingency because who the [__]
like on paper to hire an attorney go all
the way to trial and do eight days of
trial you're a milk that's a million
dollars
so they originally tried getting three
and then the court reduced it to three
hundred thousand so like that wouldn't
even come close to covering the legal
expenses that this guy would have to pay
so I'm assuming what happened is his
attorney
took the case on contingency
and attorneys once they take a client
they can't leave
it's illegal for them to just bail and
be like nah this isn't worth it anymore
so he has to follow it through
because I can't imagine that he's paying
that so then Paltrow is counter suing
for one dollar and attorneys fees
holy [__] this is crazy
I'm never going skiing again I'll tell
you what man
see my pretty face after a little bump
on the bunnies slope actually what's
crazy is Gwyneth Paltrow who was
she's skiing she mind her own business
and now she got to go sit in court for
eight days and face this idiot
probably been dealing with this for
seven years seven years
that's [__] insane
these clips of her they're turning me
into a little bit of a stand really
being honest and trust me I'm no fan of
Gwyneth she's like a con she's a con
woman the whole goop
um goop the whole goop Empire is just
obscene
did she get sued for the she had like
the vagina rocks and all kinds of shoes
getting sued all the time for her she
did have the vagina rocks I don't know
if that was what she got sued over she's
constantly selling like Homeopathy [__]
and making claims that have no evidence
and prop just aren't true so she's
constantly getting sued for [__] like
that I think
but um
there's some great clips
let's see so Sanderson who's suing her
he described himself as a careful and
frequent skater
I think on the bunny slope
I just don't know describe the incident
as he recalled it including seeing signs
warning skiers to slow down
there were there were Sons damn it
did you not read the sign that said Slow
Down the incident allegedly took place
on the bunny slub let's see Sanderson
claims Gwyneth hit him and then fled
hidden from Lee hit a run he's going
down she's going down a hill on skis you
can't stop you can't stop
at least I'm not good enough to stop
yeah you can stop but
again bunny slopes maybe they don't know
yet I haven't learned how to uh what is
it is it pizza to slow down
a pizza and then french fry to go fast
right like yeah Pizza it's a french fry
Pizza french fry because it's like how's
that pizza oh because because you like
make the skis go like this I don't know
I I skied once in my life and I was
terrible at it and it was yeah I was
like 11. so it's a little a little hazy
for me also don't you have to be rich to
ski regularly like you have to be rich
that's it
I don't think so it's like I thought it
was like a rich person's I mean it's
definitely it's not cheap expensive but
it just kind of depends I mean if you
live near
a mountain uh I'm sure like a season
pass probably isn't is relatively
affordable a big bear is the closest
skiing place to LA and it every time it
snows it's like hell there
[Music]
was also uh there's one closer from Big
Bear that there is
yeah I'm trying to remember so anyway uh
she hit him and fled
Paltrow claims that Sanderson was
actually the one that hit her
I got hit in my back so hard he said am
I right the right side on my shoulder
blade it felt like it was perfectly
centered the fists and the pulls were
right there at my shoulders blades well
better it hits me than hits you
serious serious smack I've never been
hit that hard in my life he said of 70
pound Gwyneth Paltrow on the bunny slope
so the impact sent him flying
and that all he saw was snow as he went
out of control
the last thing he remembered
he said was thinking he should protect
his face and head
[Music]
earlier testimony had also focused on
his health issues
Witnesses including his doctor and
daughter okay yeah I'm sure I trust his
daughter
have testified about his medical
problems including brain injuries
symptoms of brain injury
bro you're 76. don't blame yourself the
concussion is uh
brain injury
[Laughter]
so I don't know maybe it's what listen
it's possible I don't have all the
details and maybe he does have a
legitimate case because one thing I
always think about
is how much we all [__] on the hot
McDonald's coffee lady right we all [__]
on hot McDonald's coffee lady and it
turns out she was actually totally in
the right in that situation very true so
this one's different though because
nobody contended whether or not she had
spilled like this one's a literal he
said she said and it's like we don't
know who hit who listen bro if you can't
take a bump on the bunny slope you're
too old to be out there brother
that was kind of my like Snap reaction
too but like you said it's so it so
depends on how it actually went down
he's like I can't ski anymore yeah
you're 76. right he's like no I can't
ski luckily with all my free time I'm
running for congress well he was uh he
was 69 at the time of the accident or
thereabouts so a little bit younger
Jacqueline uh said I work in corporate
and it's absolutely an ex executive type
Leisure activity the more I got promoted
the more I noticed skiing being
mentioned deaf or rich person support I
agree because all of the gear is super
expensive
the past is expensive
I saw a lot of people in the chat though
saying like I'm not rich and I ski so
again I mean if you live
if you live somewhere where there's a
mountain nearby and and you know if
you're in Colorado or some right and
like you get a season pass for like 150
200 bucks or whatever for the lift I
guess you gotta own the skis too which
is probably a little pricey I think
right maybe just in La as I think about
it as some kind of executive
um burrito you guys want burritos
I mean
I think I'm good on food so
I'm the only one that's hungry if that's
the case I'll just wait
I'll just wait 45 sure I can get you a
break no it's okay it's okay I only got
if nobody's else is hungry
we know about you can I have one that's
not a consideration I think I agree I
think it's canceled oh thanks you want a
burrito we can't we gotta bring it like
an hour ago I want another one that was
what I was like but you just ate an hour
ago you're a Madman I'm hungry we can
get boba there was a few bars always
want something send me your Boba orders
everybody I just want this one that I
know I like the Honeydew yeah no coffee
no coffee no coffee just honeydew
what does anyone recommend one a new one
for me to try have you tried brown sugar
just a clean classic what's herb that's
called brown sugar right yeah there's
the brown sugar what's in it it has like
a brown sugar like syrup on the bottom
thank you but is it coffee is it tea
like what's in it it's like caramel
pretty much right or if for the lack of
a better what's the liquid made out of
chocolate mocha you know Brown yeah
they're all different flavors
I'll take a coffee one I do want a
coffee one okay that's what I'll take a
coffee but no matcha I think that was it
yeah it tastes like fish do you I think
I hate matcha it turns out do they do
they make the coffee with black coffee
or do they put like uh this cream in it
chocolate milk okay so let me try this I
want a super caffeinated one
no matcha lots of boba Thai tea Maybe
Thai tea
that stuff's too sweet for me okay
I think I can make it 25 sweet
yeah you guys know I'll figure it out
sweet so if you if you don't like sweet
you should just get
not waste that sweet milk okay you know
what just give me the Honeydew one I'm
not taking any chances it's
heartbreaking when it doesn't work out
all right so um here's the clips now uh
the trial is ongoing and these are
fantastic so she's testifying
and the dude's attorney who my theory of
course is that she's
taking all the women she's got to be on
contingency just got sucked into this
Vortex so she's making the best of it
she's trying to become best friends with
Gwyneth as she's uh
questioning her take a look
goggles a helmet yes okay kind of look
like everybody else on the slope
that's always
probably had a better ski outfit though
I bet I still have the same one
that you look good out there though girl
I bet you fit in but you still stand out
you can never fit in sweetheart
beautiful
I still have the same one
may I ask how tall are you I know but
that's not it's cute it was a cute
moment
well sometimes we turn out to be besties
at the end of the day
this is a horrible way to characterize
it's more than besties it's sisters
as you can see ladies and gentlemen the
jury she is just so down to earth and
cool and nice
my case is rested I rest my case let me
ask how tall you are how tall are you
just under five ten okay I am okay
shorty I think I'm shrinking though you
and me both I have to work from heels
just to make it to five five so they're
very nice oh thank you hey guys
listen we're not this isn't Mahjong
we're not we're in court I'm obsessed
with this you remember oh it's so good
no wonder it's gonna take eight days
these people think they're up there to
chit chat
it's crazy
[Music]
10. okay I am so jealous I think I'm
shrinking though you and me both I have
to wear four inch heels just to make it
to five girl you don't need the
microphone for this
uh your honor can we have an aside
please
uh so yeah no I'm so jealous tell me
about your hair what's your hair routine
five five so they're very nice oh thank
you and you're not trained in accident
reconstruction
me yeah no neither am I I was yelling
lady are you on trial too
oh she's not a great lawyer it turns out
and uh she's a little bit Starstruck she
can't believe she's actually in court
with Gwyneth Paltrow
people saying it's a tactic I mean maybe
she's trying to disarm her okay by being
Charming or something yeah absolutely
it's a tactic she's just doing it very
creepily Gwyneth did you do the crime no
me neither yeah I didn't either what are
you doing later
I thought about that I don't know that
it's I know that there's a tactic to
make the
witness warm to you so you feel
comfortable yeah I don't know that
that's what she's doing
maybe maybe not maybe she's maybe she is
and she's just not great at it
that's an option too
pretty loud I like to just think they're
in love
I think it's cute
second did I've actually I've seen this
a lot I I do think that is what she's
doing I mean that makes it makes sense
but I've seen I ain't never seen it like
this I mean the eyes are a little
there's a little bit of an extra Sparkle
to her eyes but
and and my for my final question misses
uh Gwyneth Paltrow what are you doing
later hmm
are you free grabbing it grab a drink
no at the hotel I just have one more
question Mrs
Paltrow
what was it like working with Wes
Anderson I just I have to know I have to
know how's your mom life Tanner great
actress as well by the way Miss Paltrow
is your room number I have to ask
do you have any more of those vaginal
eggs
here I need another Jade egg yeah
upset right you're small But Mighty
actually you're not that small you're
loud
me yeah me no neither am I that's a good
Sound by the way pretty loud pretty
forceful that was pretty upset right
you're small But Mighty
actually you're not that small and I'm
assuming okay rude did you just call her
fat
well I think she's saying she's tall she
was admiring her yes yes look at these
people these poor [__] people they
have lives they have families
you think that this is an eight-day
trial do you think that they have to
like get in a hotel and not read the
media and stuff to not be influenced
it's like the O.J Simpson trial it's a
crash on the bunny his slope high
profile these people are probably
they're in a [__] hotel room and they
can't talk to their families for eight
days because it's a hope high profile
lawsuit of the [__] bunny slope
incident
okay
this is so stupid
[Music]
bunny slopes and ate the trials baseball
picks and Jade eggs in my vagina
in my vagina squeeze Jade egg so you can
lift power lifting with your vagina
thank you here that you're a good Tipper
yes okay fantastic I wouldn't expect
anything less
hi I'm dick Tiff
Mr Bunny whatever if it's a strategy
whatever it's funny actually you're not
that small
okay and I'm assuming that small you're
under oath here that you're a good
Tipper sorry but that is just too much
for me you're on let me remind you young
lady you are under oath
[Applause]
let I have one more question under oath
if I may do you find me attractive
you are under roof little lady
wait somebody in the audience just the
members said they're in the court
audience
strange experience wait she's in the
court right now I think that's illegal
what no the the people that you were
pointing out aren't the jury those are
just observers they're just why are
these people sitting there because it's
the trial of the century dude how did
they even get in there I think you just
first come first serve to be in the
in the the so they were confused I don't
know
like a like a damn I mean there wasn't a
lot of detail they just Rye a member for
three months said I'm in the court
audience strange experience send me a
photo and prove it no picture didn't
happen
all right show me if show me a photo and
then I'll tell you what to do
scream
[Music]
yeah we need our own version of that
I don't know what it is but I do think
we do Hunger FF hunger FF
happy 21st third birthday do
yeah Sierra
see you guys at Zach Lewis live at the
Roxy she says let's go thank you see you
there
see you there
um
Baba Bowie
if anyone has any ideas for stuff that
you can disrupt public events
let me know you could just shout my name
you said that I'm your Bubba Dan Dan
swordless dance word love wherever you
go the wizard The Wizard yeah it doesn't
really hit love Ethan clubs Ethan
Glenn's penis Waka Flocka
how about look up Howie Mandela deleted
tick tock
I even though deleted Tick Tock I
thought it was Jello I thought it was
Jello
just to keep the Howie Mandel keep
terrorizing that poor man Howie's
prolapse how he's prolapse how is
prolapse
Flocka Flocka yeah so uh she is
killing it of course in her
brutal grilling of Gwyneth Paltrow
there's more clips though of course
here is um
another one you skied into my [__]
back
and that's when you were Furious
directly into my effing back
at the top of your lungs yes I did okay
wait wait wait wait is this not her
lawyer this isn't her lawyer no it's the
opposing counsel because she just she
literally was just like you on the scene
screamed that he hit you
which disproves their whole case
I imagine there's probably more we're
seeing we're seeing a very short out of
context clip she's surprised saying
based off of your testimony you said
this correct like wanting her declare
yeah I want to read into that too much
you were
worse but if the fact that she did say
that at the scene really doesn't help
him because his his theory is that his
claim that she slammed into him and then
moved on but if she's there saying like
hey you hit me that undermines the whole
thing
and said you
said you directly into my effing back
at the top of your lungs yes I did okay
I apologize for my bad language
and well in fact you were screaming that
so hard you were worried that Moses was
hearing you yes okay
um and after you were screaming eight
days my friends
Moses like
religious Moses she's totally she's a
religious person yes she thought Moses
in heaven could hear her screaming hit
my [__] back no I'm assuming it's got
to be a real person
I've just got to be a real person named
Moses who's out there
it's her son there you go oh oh right
Moses and apple their names Moses god
uh Gwyneth Paltrow couldn't have found a
worse attorney if she tried okay
interesting
all I'm doing is asking the question
well but still
sustained so you were the what that said
she was there from Collision to leaving
for eight to ten minutes
yes sir false true or false
I don't want an objection your honor
that you need to decide if he objects
that's true that is true what the [__]
what is happening and you know at least
the other girls working for free this
dude's probably getting paid like 800 an
hour you know what I found working with
these big um firms the most expensive
attorneys that they send out are the old
[__] ones that have been there
forever but they lost their step like
decades ago
um and this is what I'm seeing here
because this there's no way that she
doesn't have like a
really expensive lawyer that would be my
assumption as well
yes or false yes
could you not recall the the word no
yes or uh what's the word uh you're so
nervous
he's probably never been on I mean
there's a lot of people watching Jackson
yeah yeah
he objected to his own [__] question
that is a straight up comedy that's true
I don't want an objection your honor
that don't get to decide if he objects
that's true that is true wow
eight days my friends
eight [__] days of that [__]
uh unrelated but also interestingly as
we're recording this right now Gwyneth
is getting absolutely
destroyed I think on social media for
this clip I've seen lots of doctors
and health professionals quote tweeting
and being like she is so dumb and awful
um
here it is
you guys all seen this or just me I
don't know if it's just my Tick Tock
feed or
I haven't seen it oh have you seen this
love
and nope okay so wow I guess I'm in the
during the week kind of Vortex you're in
the weeds I'm in the I love medical Tick
Tock those guys are awesome
as we're recording this right now you
have a little IV so which is so on brand
for both of us we pod and IV at the same
time I'm really embarrassing myself
right here people want to ask about IVs
I love an IV I'm an early IV adopter
glutathione an early IV adopter
how old are you
she's 49 I believe let me double check
yeah I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure IVs
predate her
no she's like no no recreationally
so well here let me finish the clip the
thion I I love to have in an IV kind of
a random more fringy one
phosphatidylcholine that's my favorite
IV when I can find them they're quite
hard to find which which is what I'm
hearing there is like there's real
people that need these IVs who are sick
oh boy and I'm competing with them Sean
what is it called phosph let me go back
and then I asked for title calling
that's for title coal line
oh I see it that that that that that
that that
apparently she takes IVs that have like
sugar and vitamins and stuff to so that
she doesn't have to eat
sick that sounds really healthy
she does not look that she doesn't look
great how old is she 50. she's fit I
mean she she looks oh stop she looks
great she looks on her healthy I think
she looks unhealthy I think
great like you know her skin is nice and
everything and her hair looks good but
she looks unhealthy she looks like gaunt
don't you think
I say what you mean she looks a little
bit she looks fine it's too perfect
almost
be when I can find them that's how you
look in eight years Ethan that's what
I'm saying I won't look emaciated I'll
tell you that
that's true too it's one thing I've
never had
and those make me feel so good but this
today just because I was flying I have
just a bag of good old-fashioned
vitamins
so she does IVs I guess many times a day
what did you learn about this bag that
she's stealing from hospitals uh I I
found a uh some pages about it but
they're all from websites like something
something wellness and like it's clearly
like Sparrow Wellness Center rahav
wellness
I'm trying to find some objective
information here
um here NIH
publication about it let me let me read
up on it here
so I just saw a lot of doctors stitching
this and one of them showed a clip of
her being like
this guy asks her you can find this clip
it's the same interview he goes what's
the weirdest Health thing you've ever
done and she goes I used to put ozone up
my ass
and the doctor's like listen people have
been asking me what I think about this
interview he's like and all you got to
hear is that she was putting ozone up
her ass Nothing Else Matters nothing
else matters you can discount the rest
but yeah try to find that one that one
was very good
just drink water I mean what the [__]
you you sent that one I remember you
know I mean just drink water and eat
like some [__] strawberries
Greek yogurt some Greek yogurt I'll make
you a Perfect Blend
of nuts and berries mm-hmm
we're recording this right now
[Music]
yo did we got those um Bubbies on the
way is there ETA
yeah
estimated arrival 350. okay that's not
bad not bad not bad you love that you
know in places like Ibiza like party
places or like typical party
destinations they have like uh Hotel
people who come to your hotel when
you're like drunk and IV you so you get
less drunk faster yeah
it's pretty crazy wait you can get an IV
of alcohol
that'd be sick no I think you might be
to not have a hangover yeah that's
pretty that's really normal practice I
don't think it helps to be honest with
you I don't think it does anything
we just drink Gatorade it's like the
same [__] right I guess it probably
doesn't help anymore than just hydrating
normal you take an IV because you can't
consume liquid and it's to hydrate right
replenish your electron I mean
mainlining it probably I guess it maybe
Works a little faster but in drinking
water maybe a little bit
yeah you're right I mean just just drink
water just drink some water man
the old she goes just good old-fashioned
IVs no good old-fashioned drinking in a
glass of water
I'm going back through our group chat
looking for this uh so that's where my
um my Gwyneth Paltrow section ends so
thank you to Gwyneth who I both admire
or no not admire I sympathize with her
and also thinks she's a weirdo
thank you
people say I'm not nuanced in my takes
well suck on that
it is a shame to go here life without an
IV of pseudolexoflica flack
coursing through your veins
it is a shame
to go your whole life
without getting an IV of Sudafed a Vinyl
fluoride I found it
thank you
you just you send so many tick tocks
that going through our okay group chat
looking for it took a while oh this is
the guy yeah this is the guy okay thank
you I'm
a lot of people talk about the Gwyneth
Paltrow interview and the fact that she
was getting an IV and talks about
different
fast that she does and how little she
eats and how she looks
almost no one is talking about her
mention of the use
of rectal ozone
and I want you to know from me as a
physician when someone discusses their
use of rectal ozone you don't need to
talk about anything else that they
recommend or do or pursue when you can
completely discount and disqualify
everything else that person has to say
once they even say the term rectal Ozil
ozone is the end of it that is the man
it's so funny
oh yeah he's funny this is the kind of
videos I'm super into Dr Tick Tock that
guy knows his [__] you could tell boy
you know with a beard like that that's
it you don't get
because you don't get to do that at your
work unless you're really good you know
what I mean a doctor yeah he's gonna end
up getting like a beard pube in
someone's heart right but that's the
thing he can get away with it because
he's just that good yeah if he's some
like mediocre to below average doctor
and he walks in his boss is gonna be
like [__] shave that thing off wait
do consurgents have big ass beards like
that I'm sure they can that seems
sketchy as though he looks like the the
tank a little bit he's got like a Mandy
patinky oh he does look like the potato
shouts out shout out to the ghost so
there's another funny story now
I'm going to say this it's controversial
because I know a lot of people I don't
like the Rock
I think he's been in too many [__]
movies I don't think that that's
controversial
everybody loves the rock no I feel like
in every move I feel like public
sentiment is turned on the Rock
significantly in the last couple years
Am I Wrong [__] is that right I'm not
gonna shut up you don't hold that kind
of sway anymore well I and I get this
sense from him he he's so polished and
he's got this like hey everybody I'm the
rock perfect I get the sense that he's a
real dick
like a real [__] dick
and um
the first time I heard kind of behind
the scenes thing about him was how
he has a clause in his movie contracts
that he's not allowed to lose a fight on
screen
right because it makes him look like a
[__] yeah but it's extremely bad you
lost a fight in that fictional
story beta
apparently this is actually commonplace
because there's a theory that's
psychologically if you see someone
getting their ass beat time and time
again that you won't think of them as
this leading man who's like every time
he takes this role he's like invincible
Ali is 21 uh Zach
I'm 21. [__] you there you go let's do a
poll I'm curious do you like The Rock
do you dislike The Rock
are you rock neutral
so should there be a neutral yeah third
option so you know yes you don't have to
decide you like The Rock yes no neutral
yeah
I thought here we go because like
whenever they do like popularity polls
or well-liked men in Hollywood Rock is
always at the top
he's always at the top oh [__] okay so
our fans
[__] hate his ass
or our neutral the neutral is actually
winning but it's definitely
oh no more nose than yes
so a lot of people don't have an opinion
about the rock which I think don't sit
on the fence okay you need to [__]
pick a side on the issue
I'll do that
but um
so but we talked about he's this is the
same role he's [__] he's in a jungle
or some [__]
you know and he's exploring something
and he's fighting
I don't know goon sucks he's all kinds
of goons out to get him
so now he played the black he played
Black Adam okay I I haven't Shazam and
Black Adam both seem like
the shittest tear movies by the way I'm
just you know Shazam was this ever even
a serious film like this the actor from
Shazam is being a giant baby this dude
so the first one did really well and I
remember people at the time liked it
because it's part of the DC you know uh
side of comic book movies rather than oh
shazam's DC yeah shazam's DC and black
Adams Black Adam as well no wonder they
all suck well so but that was the thing
is like all of the DC movies were had
that like very self-serious Zack Snyder
thing going on and then the shazam movie
came out
um and I didn't see it but I know a lot
of people liked it because
a lot of people compared it to like the
old Spider-Man movies like it felt like
an older School superhero movie where
it's just kind of goofy and fun or
whatever yeah um so it it seemed like a
lot of people I'm actually seeing in the
chat right now a lot of people saying
Shazam one was all right Shazam was
awesome I watched the first one I
thought it was all right yeah it was fun
it wasn't too serious it was fine it was
fun it was like goofy silly I didn't
think there was much more to the
character though I wasn't like I can't
wait for glamoring for Shazam too I
hadn't one Shazam was enough Shazam yeah
I shazammed out
my passion has shazled out
how did it do at the box office Shazam
one box office I think it did decent
I rather watch Kazam than Shazam if I'm
being on let's go that's the Kazam yeah
with Shaquille O'Neal well that's like
the wait Kazam delete me from was it was
it called Shazam no it's Kazam
the Nelson Mandela effect yeah this is
yeah weird Nelson Mandela thing with
this movie that was Sinbad with Shazam
but oh Sinbad that right but didn't Shaq
also play like a genie yeah yeah no
there's Kazan Kazam is a real movie Yes
holy [__] I had to look it up because
you started to make me do that question
my sanity yeah
okay yeah Kazam real one Shazam with
Sinbad doesn't exist no that's not a
real movie yes that's the whole like
yeah that's why it's like one of the
examples of the uh Mandela effect that
everything exam
with Sinbad or Shaq never was made Kazam
with Shaq
is a movie but why does everyone think
there's Shazam with sin that's a good
question that's why it's like it's
people use it as one of the Prime
Mandela effect things bro I swear to God
I've seen this all right see it I got
you way way way this goes deep
because there's some people who said
they found footage from the Mandela
effect no that's all it's all fake yeah
okay so yeah I mean this is this is the
I think what confuses me is this is the
movie I'm remembering but I don't
remember it being Kazam
that's that's the main theory that
people have of why there's like this
Collective memory is people are
misremembering this movie and for some
reason substituting in Sinbad
who was very popular around that time
that that movie came out so I guess it's
not
totally
out of left field okay well
I don't even [__] remember what I was
oh yeah so here how the [__] do we even
get on that oh Shazam the movie
right there is now a movie called Shazam
but there was not an old Shazam with
Sinbad let's see a gross 140
million 225 in other territories
worldwide was 370. so
it seems like a lot of money I don't
know how much they spend on this [__]
though
you know
but that's a lot of money
so you've got Shazam two
came out
yes to uh a uh
cold reception although apparently the
fans liked it I ain't watching this [__]
hell no I don't give a [__] I mean the
die-hards are always gonna like it but
you know that's not what they by the way
I think this guy went to my high school
that what
I think he did Zachary Levi that's his
name yeah let me see sinbed Sinbad is
that
let me see
Thacker like when you were there no no
he's older than me he's older than me
does your high school start with a B
hold on let me see if this is if I'm
getting yo bro wait you guys are the
same age bro
no you guys are the exact same age no
he's 42. exactly he was born
and
he was born in Louisiana oh no Finch was
right Ventura California
when he was a child his family moved
across the state returning home to
Ventura California
you guys were we're like
we're like we're dogs we're the mascot
the Bulldog go Bulldogs go Bulldogs yes
we're dogs we have so much in common I
mean just I don't I didn't like the
movies but uh we we could be dogs dude
I did not [__] my dog
there it is if you go to my high
school's Wikipedia page there's not a
lot of notable people that came out of
that school and sadly I'm on it
so that doesn't speak well for them
Buena High School Wikipedia let's see
you're on the list of famous I think so
alumni I think so notable alumni
yeah I'm on it
see I don't have my own page yet that's
the problem you guys are causing me all
kinds of trouble with that
but this page is sad yo look at this
[__] Kelsey
boutita
from The Amazing Race
uh Owen Bucy
he's he's like Gary Busey's son or
something
Owen Bucy
Kevin Costner went to my high school oh
that's a cool one that's kind of weird
Troy Dumas 2012 Olympic diver
Aaron Goldberg
Jew
a musician and filmmaker thank you thank
you thank you
you're a Jew
that's what Kanye hears in his head
[Music]
um there's not a lot you know which is
interesting because it's a pretty big
high school so just a bunch of losers
this look at this idiot Kevin paffrath
YouTuber and unsuccessful candidate I
remember this guy loser
unsuccessful loser I just want to looked
up my high school and I'm sad to report
I'm not I'm not a notable alumni either
we'll get how many are on your thing a
lot more than this uh it's about the
same my dream is to get on mine too but
I keep getting [__] you know what
are people actively screwing you over
Zach no it's just it's not on there yet
if you get a Wikipedia page you'll
probably go up there yeah well there's
some there's some Heavy Hitters on mine
so you'll be there one day buddy really
and then when some sound lead sees your
name you know he's gonna scream out
but I can't say it
and then if you go to like notable UCSC
alumni
I feel like I should be on this it's not
a very long list of people and a lot of
them are just like who like I'm sorry
who Susan wojinski okay whatever
astronaut okay that's fire Andy Samberg
he's way more famous Huey P Newton okay
fair enough she's way more famous
Rudolph all these people are way I guess
I guess maybe the bar is a little bit
higher here's this guy John Peretti oh
Huffington Post okay that's a big deal
and BuzzFeed founder yeah no that's a
big deal that's a big deal Carrie
fukunaga dude he rocks you know him yeah
that's the uh he directed um and show
ran um True Detective okay
so that's pretty good right I think I'll
click his ass click his ass
for my city
this is the first
uh one of the albums
oh one of the Abbas oh my god you're an
incredible company yeah yeah one of the
abbots
that's that's like a god right Love in
Your Country Ash is famous yeah uh this
Reina Grande she's apparently an
award-winning author which award way
more prestigious Bell hooks critically
acclaimed author okay
who's acclaiming her
Stefano block academic graffiti artist I
know him he's famous so I guess yeah
like probably the bars a little bit
higher Julian Welsh who's that click on
it
we need to get I need to get her out and
meet in
she performs nine critically acclaimed
albums
yada yada whatever Bluegrass appellation
you went to college and Santa Cruz no
but it is kind of hippie dippy [__]
that's not hippie dippy [__] no it fits
it fits
I don't know how to explain it
Appalachian Bluegrass that's the vibe in
Santa Cruz no but every there everyone's
got a place in Santa Cruz anyone can fit
in there okay fair enough for sure I
mean I'm just looking at all the time
she lost
Ethan Klein YouTuber
who doesn't even have his own page fat
I'm on the wicked video for Dearborn
you made Dearborn yeah so you're the
most famous of all of us
I think we saw that before but how did
what did they mention you it says
internet personality H3 podcast crew
member
let's see uh notable people oh they're
really generous we surprisingly have
more than you expect myth is on there
too myth
I'm the last one on that list maybe
ayad do you wait you have your own page
everything it's just like stations but
that's the same like I don't have my own
page everything goes back to this right
I mean it is my it's all the same yeah I
mean it is you look it's just like
Ryan Cavanaugh's been busy on the
controversy section
Hussein's on it that's not controversy
trailer of course YouTube suspensions
thank you
Ethan said someone should be word the
NRA
thank you very much
thank you very much the same channel
received a strike and one week
suspension following comments directed
at Jewish conservative political uh
political commentator Ben Shapiro
in which Ethan states he wished as he
would be all right remember yeah yeah he
added and the yada yada
well I always say I wish Ben would be
the first at my house this Passover to
enjoy a wonderful meal right
is this Passover this week next this
weekend oh it's this weekend okay wait I
thought it's April uh
the fifth well we're having it this
weekend
I think April next Wednesday yeah okay
we're doing it this weekend we don't we
don't care about you jump in the gun
nah we just do it we do it when we want
to do it I noticed that Olivia stood up
and left I'm hoping that means the Bob
is here
so you know what's funny before the
Kavanaugh stuff it was really simple now
it's just all controversy
Twitter suspension
that's not how is that noteworth none of
this is no like what yeah like I got
Ethan Klein's Twitter account received a
permanent suspension I'm back baby
after impersonating Elon Musk
anti-slap motion like podcast was
involved in several lawsuits wait is
this about how I lost the recent one
hold on
because we're appealing that it's it's
meaningless it's involved in several
lawsuits against triller and Ryan
Kavanaugh most of which
most of which thus far have resolved
incline's favor okay
well one remains an act of litigation
that's not true there's two
it's not even accurate poorly written
too it calls the h3h3 podcast it's the
H3
this is not talk too much [__] let me
see who no this is straight up in my
opinion what if it's one of our
no it's not one of our it's Cav kev's in
my opinion have Kev
I just don't want to talk any [__] on
our boys
dude those guys like thrust and Pokey
they're like don't get anything wrong
dude their [__] is tight
uh this this the relevance of this
lawsuit could have severe financial
implications and be a precedent setting
case for what it claims to be the
weaponization of clients H3 fan base to
damage Kavanaugh's reputation via social
media okay that's straight at it yeah
yeah it's just like copy pasted from his
uh article he paid for yeah see why is
this allowed on here this is like
obvious what's not but I think it's just
not you know how closely are people
watching it yeah I don't check my
Wikipedia page on like Kavanaugh who
lives on it
oh let's [__] goals
[Music]
so he's been busy he's been busy
oh they acknowledge my um charitable
spirit
thank you gave away a hundred thousand
dollars
excellent thank you so much
this is exciting
this is so funny the outcome of the
lawsuit may have a precedent setting
effect regarding overall online speech
and the legal reach of popular internet
influencers in the legal accountability
for endorsements and statements
shut the [__] up Kavanaugh shut the [__]
up idiot
well go for it I mean this guy really
thinks there's a war being fought on
Wikipedia I'm not doing chat
I don't care
I don't care bro right now there's just
this Great Divide you know there's a
fight
still better than yours
Drive Angry
your socks bro you're like a criminal
wait a minute refresh the refresh the
Wikipedia page real quick oh wait mine
live updates look at the top look at the
first sentence there
oh YouTube personality he may be fat
they got me there
what the hell they need to put a
reference for that
citation needed
Yahoo news how controversial influencer
Ethan Clan Rose to fame from feuds and
Frenemies to being banned from YouTube
for a week I've never I didn't even read
this yet you know what the [__] is this
here's my problem you have all these
dummy or you know let me rephrase that
you have all of these super credible and
hard-hitting journalists like cat barge
whatever and the others who are they
working for like all these media
companies and they're just writing like
the dumbest most gossipy [__] for click
bait only just for clicks and then
Wikipedia is like oh yeah that's legit
it's like what the [__] dude really
nobody cares
what the hell what the [__] is this why
did they do this
who wrote this whole thing what the [__]
is this it's so long just checked
wait why is it so long
it's a book so long before you dismiss
it I gotta say this looks pretty
comprehensive this is like a whole
story of the entire broadcast from
Charlotte Colombo not not I don't want
to say like uh I thought you said who
was it by didn't you yeah I was curious
because I don't I don't want anyone to
get harassed or anything it's not like
well I'm saying that it looks like they
did a pretty good job I'm complimenting
Charlotte
as long as it's nice
I mean factual do we really need to talk
about leafy is here Philip DeFranco my
greatest enemy
oh my God my hair is so black that must
have been part of a bet
Ethan was accused of being a backstabber
who writes that
after he gave his views on PewDiePie's
racism allegations
I mean that is a thing so far this is
all factual everything you haven't read
it I'm saying it so far everything
you've pointed out
no they're not making [__] up it's right
like give me a break dude
it's like they the coconars videos
[__] newsworthy
[__] am I in there what does it say this
isn't this caption this is just the
caption of the of the photo following
the Fallout of Video Vigilante Ethan's
own subreddit turned on him that's a
true that did happen coconaro YouTube's
historical preservation Society
what say what what
wait I don't understand that part
it says Goku Naro comma YouTube
historical preservation Society slash
YouTube
dude the celebrated turns on me every
other day not newsworthy
let's see
did they link to the video
O's upload re-uploaded by YouTube
historical preservation Society got it
weird
um
they did it man they put in the work
foreign
star of course
my friend my lover my closest Ally
he means everything to me
it's crazy though
hey you're a public figure
I guess so I've been through a lot of
[__] eh
it's been a long road
this is from two art two years ago they
gotta update this article there's so
much more yeah now I'm like a nice guy I
haven't been in any trouble it's all
good yeah everybody loves me yeah there
hasn't been anything there's no personal
threats no lawsuits
I feel like Charlotte did a good job
documenting the history thank you
Charlotte I wanna
do not go after Charlotte people
they're doing journalism here just this
is important
leafy is here and Ela clashed
oh no leafy is here and climb clashed
after an autistic YouTuber
said they were getting death threats
after Leaf he made a video about them
okay
mm-hmm
there it is my life story and somebody
said it's the script for the lore video
that's that's my life story brought to
you by Yahoo news
damn these things so hard and [__]
bubbles oh good
okay here is proof that Shazam happened
look at this [__] people really be
[__] with us
it's a genie with an attitude and he's
ready for an unforgettable Adventure
Sinbad and Shazam
uh okay let's talk about the Black Adams
thing we got like sidetracked into
Oblivion
Big Black Adam Black Adam not Black
Adams plural did he not say that
what I swear you said big black Adam I
am black no
what did you say me
Black Adam singular not plural you keep
saying Black Adams hmm
he's Black Adam black is that a little
bit it's like is he just a dude named
Adam who's black
I'm not sure I didn't watch it
I don't know [__] about Black Adam I
think he's in the comics I think he's
kind of an anti-hero like he's kind of a
bad guy but I think the rock uh
uh I think the movie
depicts him as more of just a normal
superhero it says Schwarzenegger was
initially hesitant about taking the
Terminator role because he would be
playing a villain but chose to be
open-minded and it became his most
iconic role whereas The Rock's ego
refused to let Black Adam be a bad guy
and it ended up sinking two franchises
yep that sounds about right
all right so let's talk about this so
Shazam versus Black Adam Shazam tanked
as we talked about
but here's
where's interesting and I guess I'm
going to defend the rock somehow the
lead actor Zachary Levy
Levi is calling out Dwayne Johnson for
being controlling and potentially
affecting the film's performance
actually no I'm not defending anyone
they're
this guy seems like a crybaby and The
Rock seems like a giant dish
he posted this story
this is really rare will you see another
celebrity come out like that against
another one like that oh yeah I need to
actor especially this is super weird
Zachary Levi seemingly confirms reports
that Dwayne Johnson blocks
Hawkman and other JSA
that Justice League right Justice
Society of America
as everybody knows JSA
we're obviously big comic heads here em
kind of is Ian what's JSA
I I've mounted the game oh God so okay
so but I understand so he had this movie
Justice Society of America it is that I
was kind of kidding okay fair enough
so here's what happened they made this
movie
and then I don't know if Black Adam was
in that movie or
in the comics these characters are
somewhat connected I believe they're
rivals in the comic do we at least know
that Ian that sounds what I understand
uh what yeah Black Adam and Shazam are
rivals in the comics uh yeah thank you
okay okay so he had some comic
credibility here so they made this movie
and rock was in it
so Zachary
is now restoring this gossip page saying
the truth will set you free it said the
rap confirms that in Shazam Fury of the
Gods the Justice Society from Black Adam
were recruiting Shazam in the post
credit so they had this whole
post-credits scene
where Shazam was supposed to join the
Justice League it was going to connect
his movie to the larger
universe and Zach was all lined up to be
a main character but the rock denied
access
and David Sandberg had to make a
last-minute decision to add Amelia and
John I don't know what that means the
rock John attempted to reconstruct
the universe centering him
around him and Henry cavill's Superman
The Rock didn't allow Zachary to cameo
in a post-credit for Black Adam
so he Shazam was supposed to be in a
post-credit for Black Adam and I think
the rock said this guy's Zack's not
famous enough
so I need to co-star Henry cavill's
Superman
real weird juicy [__]
it's like psycho ship
and he but he's restored that
that's like quite a statement I feel
like in Hollywood for two leading guys
he's throwing the gauntlet throwing the
lightning Shazam [__]
foreign
actor is calling out uh the rock for
potentially affecting the film's
performance he posted this to his story
I think that's what we just opened
uh yeah so
Levi ranting on Instagram live about how
he was thwarted
so and part of me is like a part of me
is like dude
first of all the rocks are giant douche
that's psychotic that he's doing that
but also shouldn't he just like shut the
[__] up and just like
like dude come on what are you doing
you've got like the best
you're set up so pretty bro
you don't want beef with the rock he's
the type of dude who will like pull
screens and Blacklist you
um so our intent our desire Walter
Hamada Peter Safran David Sandberg
myself everybody we had a awesome scene
that would have tied me in to the JSA
with Hawkman and with cyclone and we
were thwarted is I'm not this is not me
I'm not talking about these things I'm
trying to blame anybody for our movie
doing however well or not well it's
doing also I love the idea of him just
bitching about his movie sucking
on Instagram live it's just so
unprofessional and weird
yeah your movies suck bro your Shazam
chill
it's not that big of a deal I am merely
coming to the defense of the people that
ought to be defended I'm coming to the
defense of truth because truth it's
Shazam
it's not a truth that we need
keep the truth to yourself
also I love how he goes I'm defending
the crew who worked hard I didn't
deserve to get 50 on Rotten Tomatoes
coming to the defense of truth because
truth is good and we should all live in
it guys even when it's hard even when
it's something that well it's Shazam
truth is hard we must endure it we must
face truth down we must be brave in the
face of ultimate truths and that is why
Shazam
only got 50 percent you should have got
70 percent
is wild it's good and we should all live
in it guys even when it's hard even when
it's something that might fly in the
face of something that we already might
have believed before and now it
challenges whatever our idea or our
opinion is
we need to live in the truth okay I need
you guys to know Shazam sucked but I
need you guys to know
it could have been good it was going to
be good
okay so Avery thank you Black Adam
was called Black Adam because he brings
nothing but death in the comics he's
barely an anti-hero more of a huge
villain who loves committing war crimes
oh
well like a fun character to play I mean
if I'm being honest
I'd way rather play a villain she seems
like way more fun
[Applause]
they do seem to have more fun don't they
actors that get to play the villains
yeah yeah it's awesome
it seems like more fun to act it out
[Music]
because I feel like it's
everyone's everyone's like the good guys
like hey oh don't do that
ah sad somebody got hurt like that's
easy lame that's easy to act up
you know
so I was pretty surprised by this whole
thing
I'm pretty surprised and amused by it
because these guys are both kind of on
top of the world just whining
here's he's saying he hasn't watched
Dwayne's movie because he has too much
going on it's awesome
he [__] hates him dude
me and you too brother me and you both
I have not you haven't I'm not are you
gonna look are you gonna watch it I
I got a whole you know full plate of
other things that I need to get to in
life
was he in that movie
no I don't believe he was I think that
that was no thank you he was supposed to
be in the post-credit of that movie
I've got all kinds of different things I
need to get to in my life he said
it's not like he wasn't like I have like
I'm busy with work he's like no I have a
lot to get to in my life before I watch
that movie
it's awesome he's pissed
he really thought that he was going to
be the next big superhero he thought he
was gonna be like Ant-Man or something
but bro you're Shazam nobody cared
okay
thank you
also interesting
this is good
Zachary it turns out is it Jordan
Peterson fanboy
and he came out against Pfizer
uh an ultimate Act of bravery and Truth
uh this person tweeted do you agree or
not that Pfizer is a real danger to the
world hardcore agrees says Zach bro do
you really he's got the Wheaties box
he's don't do that next to the Wheaties
box
how is this man still like I know I
these Brands go so hard to keep their
[__]
G-rated this man is straight doing
like uh
vaccine denialism next to the Wheaties
box
it's crazy yeah DC is going through it
with the flash too they got that movie
coming out with what's his name Ezra
Miller it's the lead actor and it's like
such a big deal because what's his
name's in it um what's the old Batman uh
Michael keatonix Batman is has a cameo
or something yeah wait are they still
using Ezra yeah they are yeah oh the
movie's already done yeah oh that he's
he they already shot it that makes sense
they didn't like bring him back
no
not yet anyway they're like this version
of flat is crazy you're gonna like
recruit a bunch of girls start a sex
quote
I've seen [__] where they're trying to
run like PR campaigns for Ezra too where
like he's like oh I'm sorry my bad and
they're just trying to make framing why
because he's uh he's reformed but you
know we're not forgetting about that one
Ezra
Amber Heard in the Aquaman movie coming
out too though oh true yeah they really
Amber hers back
DC is just like let's get all the most
hated people in Hollywood and we'll put
them in a movie together that was before
the whole trial too so we'll just recast
them
you see nobody cares
nobody's like oh I need Amber Heard back
she's so important nobody would notice
if I recall correctly um
who's what's Aquaman's name Mamoa Jason
Momoa um
stood stood up for her during all that
he did yeah he because he I like Jason
he doesn't [__] ruined himself for me
yet
I may call him Jason uh
we're cool sure
um so here he is anyway Zachary Levi
on Joe Rogan
uh saying how much he loves Jordan
Peterson although what year was this
because I also
May
you know what I mean if it was like five
years ago then I can forgive it for sure
it's just recent Ian says okay so then
yeah he's a psychopath
here I think one of the
deepest thinkers that I've ever heard
don't don't break down don't say that
human behavior no no uh and
I don't know just an understanding of
all that stuff and and I think good good
wisdom along with it is Jordan Peterson
I don't say that
holy [__] dude
okay now it makes sense why he's being a
whiny little [__]
he's got like white grievances
he's like
oh
it's not fair
I was meant to be the main character
I was going to be Tony Stark
I think if he would be a person that I
would trust I think that guy has a lot
of integrity and then so I would
in this day and age for someone to
actually say this is really wild July
well once that Elliot page thing
happening was that
this was after the Elliott page
he was talking about how he loves him
that is [__] fantastic
it was like right then actually
yeah but I would that would be 72 but I
also know Jordan has his own things that
people have issues with like I get it
nobody's perfect we're not gonna find
he's kicked off Twitter right now
because he said something about Ellen
he's not kicked off Twitter he just
refused to delete the tweet
let's not run propaganda for that dumb
old idiot
right now because he said something
about Ellen Page uh Elliott page Calder
Ellen Page like I think I think that was
the number one thing the dead naming
yeah
and it's sad man because I guess like
there's a lot of fear and and pain on
and all that all the sides of all that
too my friend Brian Simpson someone says
Ethan that was a little euphrment that's
why I said when was it did you hear that
part
jeez
this is from this is from July 2022.
this is less than a year ago yeah
thank you
I also liked Elon Musk back then too
I had a very good thing to say about
that it was like I come to you for like
heavy duty intellectual [__] he goes not
for this yeah true yeah yeah this is not
totally yeah this is like yeah Jordan
don't yeah yeah yeah don't you don't
need to get into all that I mean look
it's his life it's his Twitter or was
his Twitter anyway okay well I mean
it's actually kind of surprising
they're kind of criticizing Jordan
Peterson here
but edging his bets a little bit though
kind of like Andrew type some good
things some bad things right
iOS people up man
that is one of the ones that Riles
people up like everybody's in favor of
everybody doing whatever they want to do
as long as it doesn't hurt anybody until
it gets to gender and then people start
getting weird how is that hurting anyone
or he's talking about oh yeah Jordan
yeah okay thank you Joe they start
thinking it's a mistake they start
thinking why are you doing that they
start thinking all kinds of things fine
mind your own [__] business though
thank you
it is still pretty wild like right on
the tales of that controversy to be like
you know who I think is the coolest dude
alive an intellectual heavyweight the
greatest thinker of Our Generation
[Music]
it is a shame to be Shazam
kicked out of the post-credit scenes
when you should have been the star of
the universe
I am Shazam the greatest hero that ever
lived everybody was gonna love me
it is a shame to do a podcast without
ordering Bobo
it is a shame to tour I rap without
burning down
a wheat farm some Village oh yeah
uh-huh
Alpha [__]
is a shame for a man not to get in an
ice bath and his nipples Pro took true
to hold two inches
oh hell yeah the monument is Alpha
yes the the Washington Monument
yeah it's extremely it's like a uh large
uh phallic shape is that out and it's
off as [__] is that what they meant
absolutely that was the intent
[Music]
let's see what else I got
anything interesting
I love this one this is like a nice way
to end it
um my face here's a cat this is just
wholesome nice way to sign off all right
this Chinese Chef is awesome
he's Somalian
but he lives in China
and he speaks like perfect Mandarin
he lives in like rural [__] like
rural remote China
and makes the craziest videos
almost inexplicable
um he he crafts like a whole story
and [__] I don't know where or how
but I love it let's check this [__] out
have we copy write it or check this [__]
and it has some kind of Chinese tune but
I doubt it's probably fine whatever
right
uh
I'm sorry we actually did not
that song sounds famous actually
sounds like a banger but here's this
page while we checked that real fast
um
because 180 000 followers his name is
Lao way 2023 my boy
my boy Lao way my boy
I love that Meme are you aware of that
that Panda meme no that those like
pandas are like um you know like the soy
Jacks that are used in a bajillion memes
over here
like the the small Chan one no just the
all of like those all these yeah yeah
okay yeah so they have in China this
meme that I've realized is kind of like
the equivalent of that of like this
panda with these weird faces the panda
you see what I'm talking about go back
to the wait where it's on the page you
put it up on screen for a second
you'll see it okay
where's where's the panda
oh that oh that those
they're all these little pandas oh
that's funny funny faces you know what's
it kind of reminds me of the Winnie the
Pooh she meme
I believe there actually is a she
version of that pretty sure you'll be
executed if you post that in China
though
but actually this guy's so interesting
because he speaks fluent Mandarin and
lives out in the village I don't know
the comment this man has a spy back
his existence at all is just incredible
[Music]
oh all the panda memes yeah
that's awesome
[Music]
I never seen this kind of stuff I only
ever seen him in the village
you know
we're we're checking it
stinky but tasty he said he cap yeah he
captions it
what's stinky but tasty in our world
durian fruit a lot of people say it's
the worst smelling but it tastes sweet
I don't think I've ever tried durian
cheese cheese is stinky and good yeah
absolutely
blue cheese is Spanish okay it's a good
example
unfortunately this video did get claimed
oh I'm glad we've oh
yo that sucks I love that video man
I would have been pissed if I like the
last video I show in a three hour
um actually before we go I do want to
point out that at the very top of the
show you said you had another big
announcement to share at the at the back
end of the show yeah right big
announcement hold on let me see if this
one has music
it's the same song God damn it ah damn
it
well anyway go check them out it's cool
maybe I can do it without
um sound and you guys can kinda just
enjoy it and maybe yes English captions
he's got English captions and Zach can
you kind of play me some kind of cool uh
you know
Chinese Countryside Flutie
Flutie bloody uh Chinese Countryside
yeah
I don't think I have any of that simple
country times just a simple Chinese
country yeah yeah yeah rural Chinese
tune the classic one you want just like
chill Vibe like I'm just play the one I
mean typically that I asked for yeah
right right rural Chinese
Good Times farming on a sunny day some
sort of yeah
safe farming on a sunny day this is like
happy City day I don't have farming on
it in China I'm sorry hold on
I'm on the case
this is a you know
that one's like I've got a coffee and
it's nice outside and I'm walking in the
city
I don't like uh hold on
find something else here
dead air
Zach maybe Chinese uh rural
it's just royalty free anyway let's play
it you can just play
um first result
hit me with it
hit me with that good [__] brother
hit me with that right brother
I love this song Dan hit me with that
real tasty [__] it's not playing are you
an epidemic yeah yeah me too I'm having
the same problem oh there it goes
okay okay
it's a little fast-paced
but it's not bad
more high speed than I anticipated
I like it we can keep how about sweet
flavors
you know he says what are you doing
Jamal he says there's no flower he says
that's too much you bought too much he
said I bought 10 kilograms so I can save
money it's cheaper and then he calls
this guy Uncle he says I want to cook
for you uncle and he says I have spicy
peppers wait here I'll get it for you
the way he talks makes everything better
like he hits like the dialect so hard
Ramadan he's celebrating
[Music]
shout out shout out shout out wait shut
up I'm Chinese aren't those people in
danger
uh
no not universally okay
uh so he's making some dough we love
that
mm-hmm
it's really not the same without the
sound I'll be real
it's just not the same is it just this
song should we keep trying different
songs this song is not good all right
how about
um
hold on greeted in Osaka look how he's
look how he saves his bags take a listen
to greeted by in Osaka pick this up this
is good
this one feels a little too like like it
feels a little weird but it's okay let's
hear it it's good A lot of it is how
hard he hits the accent he's like
perfect
the guy saves the bags kind of
interesting
we love a renewable King
you got the peppers mm-hmm
get it drop the peppers we got some
garlic slam them boy you know what it is
yes sir peanuts hand-picked rolled
this man is going all out for this meal
yes sir
got the uh flavors all different flavors
guys it's just the name of the song I
know I know that Osaka is in Japan
we weren't trying to make some statues
about how Japan and China are the same
country are you saying that Chinese and
Japanese people look the same
no one's saying that
wait Osaka is not in China LOL oh my God
do you have like a Beijing
the Beijing Blues
so here we go he's making
um buns this man just made buns
and he's got a tiny little tables Epic
[__] buns dude for uncle and him
look how good those look though
that man just spent all day making those
we've Auto played into the next song
this one just doesn't make any sense
I'm liking this too wait wait wait what
a nice Vibe wait wait
that feeling is wild did he take the bay
leaf and all that inedible stuff out
well are we going to talk about the buns
they look delicious oh those no those
buns are perfect
man oh my
God those buns are slapped so hard
he like talks to his food and stuff it's
awesome
I wish we could hear it
[Laughter]
cool
yeah check him out he's cool
Lao why 2023
ah Shame about the music but there it is
if only
well guys we had a fun time here today
oh what's the announcement I forgot
right massive announcement is coming to
off the rails our Wednesday episode huge
changes
the huge changes are
do we have a link somewhere or is it
just it's just we're talking about it we
don't have any Visions Word of Mouth
Word of Mouth Okay so
you see at the watermark there
H3 TV okay that's what you're watching
today oop that's off the rails so we
decided
in consultation with Ila
that this watermark
what is it she said she wanted uh
there's a few things
a few good suggestions you know where
you're going okay well for one for one
it's just that uh maybe instead of off
the rails it's H3 there
right and then also that we could
distinguish more between the backgrounds
well I thought we were
I thought we were go ahead cam I thought
we were just changing the background off
completely I thought we were completely
yeah yeah we are I just didn't know how
much I'm supposed to say so we change it
we're changing the background we're
we're rebranding I will no longer be in
the woods I have no idea what the [__]
we're gonna do with it but I'm thinking
we'll figure it out if you want to pitch
stuff in our subreddit let me know we're
out of the woods we're out of the woods
baby we're back to civilization we're
gonna put them in the desert Ethan
incline
Out of the Woods that's me
but you know I see a lot of people
saying stuff like each all the shows are
just kind of the same now
which I agree to I agree obviously the
problem so our original idea for Friday
was like just to watch zany internet
clips and as fun and as great as that is
it's not really feasible after a few
episodes because you run out of [__]
right I mean unless you're doing like
zany America's Funniest Home Video stuff
whoa did you take a look at that
fret's playing with like Fred The
Flintstones sounds
it's it's not it so we just we said okay
Friday
after Dark
and then off the rails
I mean they're always off the rails and
then Monday is like
we kind of just throw it together
because we all enjoy the weekend so
that one's kind of just thrown together
so we have a good episode here for you
guys and so let the conversation so you
have Monday which we throw together we
have Wednesday which is off the rails it
always is
and then you have Friday which used to
be clips and we ran out of clips
and Thursdays Thursday is different all
uh actually different so I don't know
you know what I mean
I see people in check concern that the
bunny's gonna go away no Monday's gonna
stay the same Monday what you see is
what you get here yeah cam is my
favorite Bunny man oh thank you Jordan I
would be down to do another content
Court though
I don't know if we have any good
subjects though
been kind of a
the villains are sitting quiet for a
minute here
you know yeah
no new villains Ethan and Roku City
that's dope idea
I've been there before
and we won't return yeah
H3 Ridiculousness exactly anyways um
yeah uh huge announcement
huge announcement massive changes coming
to the podcast we are changing the
background
and I am the new
[__] alpha dog
[Music]
that's it
oh let me see how that tick tock's doing
love oh [__] is it still popping yeah I
haven't looked in a while it's so
exciting to look back in I haven't
watched for a while let's see let's see
one oh it's at a million no way that's
crazy dude we're going big on this one
Sebastian [__] hold on to your ass kid
the alpha dogs in town baby I love that
oh Aiden's responded he said can we do
it over Discord
did we already change your mind about
that yes
[Laughter]
maybe you shouldn't fire that off so
quick no that'd be fun this would be fun
so let's say
let's say Wednesday
yeah Wednesday I mean do we have
anything for Wednesday
we do now
I don't want to bump anyone for
Wednesday but I'd be pretty I'd be I
mean I've never had a one-on-one combo
with him and I'd love to
see
oh yeah Bryce is supposed to be here
Wednesday but he ghosted us
damn why are you getting so butt hurt
why do you have to say everything out
loud why can't I say whatever I want out
loud you get like so upset for no reason
because you say things out loud all the
time and then you set an expectation and
then it doesn't happen Bryce is not
coming
he ghosted us bro
he got the call from from Kavanaugh
here I'll text him right now thank you
thank you we on for Wednesday
or did you get the call
from Kavanaugh
I mean I texted him this is my first
time texting him since uh
we made contact being like Hey we're
this is it this is it what was the
second text like you up I said I know I
said so we all good for next week that's
it
and then I just said are we on for
Wednesday or did you get the call from
Kavanaugh
but I have a feeling he's out
but Aiden would be fun
I've never had a one-on-one with him
let's say Wednesday afternoon
Wednesday at 2 p.m
[Music]
alrighty listen y'all uh great God bless
it is what it is and it ain't what it is
and uh if it ain't what it ain't
can it be n in it can it it ain't and it
is
it ain't and it is
facts bro no caps
all right y'all we'll see you on
Wednesday and uh God bless so stay be
good stay good members I'll see you
tomorrow for the
uh see you next Tuesday we'll always
have a lot of fun there
and um
until then stay God blessed
and remember if you see me on the street
you need to cry I need tears
so that I can and then if I if it's okay
could I record it and send it to
Sebastian
so keep your eyes open and have your
consent form ready
bye everybody
foreign